me
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
yes sir
enter the 36 chambers
we'll take clan strikes again the
wrestler the gizza oh dirt
y'all know what it is what's going on
rome talk to me suicide kings i see you
got the w up what's going on how my
levels are sounding talk to me around
gerald mack what up hustler motivate i
see you hd tv i like that name fire star
66 joe mac the legend lloyd metro
year
let's get it hustle thank you brother
we'll take driving safely got you again
oh for you come
[Music]
they're coming for the kids
sick what's up i'm waiting for my
firmware what's up what's going on good
show today good show today we got the
legend
cj grinnell no doubt what's going on w
yes sir tess yes what's going on my vex
brother addict talk to the people right
quick let them know what's going on
what's going on guys
yeah
let's go let's go it ain't nothing that
you already don't think ain't that let's
go
should never put that out it's over
trying to grow yeah yeah no doubt all
right you gonna install it today no
doubt that's what's up man
listen man
protect the kids i feel you i feel you
addict levels is good so yeah we gonna
get the legendary chris grinnell in here
i'm just gonna tell y'all right now
full disclaimer king has something
planned i don't know what it is
but something is planned when we get to
uh certain segments i think y'all know
what that is but look we're gonna have
some fun
my man oh man they throw the crest up i
mean dj oros what's up bro yeah i know
he's supposed to rot you gotta text me
bro if you don't text me i'm still
working it at you so you already know
what that is
but um
it's going to be crazy crazy crazy i
know what y'all here for what's the
what's the gladiator are you not
entertained
you know what he's here for there's a
lot of talk
you know i gotta you know i would try to
regulate it as best i can but other
people are like yo you gotta let him go
it's his moment so we'll see we'll see
how i go but i'm gonna talk to y'all
[Music]
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
um
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tiller uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is
i'm anti-social love my city but i'm
still by coastal
um
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
fire this is their yoga fire flame they
think it's arcing up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with
the gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
don't stop
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
that's
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
and turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
um
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals follow on twitter but
i'm anti-social my city but i'm still by
coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with the gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boil you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell the uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger that's
let's do
[Music]
a
it
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if i can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cause if you don't
give her that option you're gonna be
single player like siren you're gonna
get tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's an avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be me though i know it's
my destiny works incognito
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible was it and nothing
is cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
all right there you hear ye and we are
live welcome to the iron lords podcast
llc and also live on lords of gaming.net
episode number 230 it's another glorious
sunday we're back at the round table on
the lord's day i'm extremely excited
about our special guest and we've got
sony game development game past
subscription targets god of war to pc
and phil's
king's face phil spencer and booty
recent interviews to discuss so we gonna
get right into it
i want to introduce a lord whose
tremendous passion and experience within
the world of game design has affected so
many classic sony franchises we have
grown to love and watch evolve within
our games industry
introducing the former senior game
designer for sony studio liverpool and
gorilla games plus the current founder
and ceo of the urban zoo sports platform
the lord of f1 wipeout end kill zone by
day
who is also the lord of combat sports
and dj tran sessions by night
live from liverpool where you will never
walk alone and making his proper debut
into the realm of the lords
mommy
lord chris grinnell how we doing sir
oh god thank you
that was an awesome intro thank you very
much to getting us going for for today's
session
yeah just absolutely um ecstatic to be
here you know we've been uh
we've been trying to plan this for a
good few months and obviously we're all
busy you guys have got a busy and uh
awesome schedule as always so we need to
fit things in and i'm just uh drowning
in work and stuff
we got it done so yeah really happy to
be here with you guys happy we finally
get it done again apologies i know
schedule's been crazy you've been
extremely
understanding
let's get that out the way and i
appreciate you brother because i know
obviously we've had you to run before
but we had to do it proper way you had
to roll out the red carpet we got sony
royalty game development game design
royalty but outside all that what have
you been playing lately
so uh playing recently i've just been uh
living on far cry 6. i think it's uh
absolutely
it's one of those but it's been received
um you know it's been a bit frosty with
some of the uh something that's being
received unfairly
it's been
received on families
it's being it it's being attacked for
not being something other than what it
is
but the same people be given
people give every year give call of duty
9 10 out of 10. so yeah exactly
because call of duty doesn't need to be
anything else so
yeah
it's an awesome game it's far cry it's
what we love about far cry um
jumping in co-op with friends is just is
awesome um they've obviously made that a
little bit more friendly in terms of
pickups and so on and so forth they're
like shared so not progression but at
least yeah at least you're getting some
some loot and weapons and stuff on the
go but it's just awesome it's like what
a
what a world what a what a place to
explore um the good play is you know
superb as always um
so i've been playing that i've been
jumping into a bit of circuit superstars
[Applause]
okay
i was hoping
i was hoping you could see this guys for
some time um
and yeah obviously i think square picked
it up uh halfway through the dev cycle
um okay and it's just an awesome game
it's a
nice little top-down arcade racer it's
got some cool
physics and it's got some like controls
to master once you get to it some of
those online races boy
people are people are fast out there
it's hot and heavy let me let me ask you
a quick question on it because um you
know for me i know i put it up on
twitter you had responded and you know
for me i love the art style the art
style is like it's really beauty
beautiful and then it's more hardcore
like you said like than you think like
you think it's this cutesy it's going to
be easy i was coming into it saw the
kick thinking it's going to be like
motorola for tg16 just you know casual
with motorola last person in the back he
would get dragged automatically right no
no no no no no no no no not this this is
for the real hardcore like there is
technique you've got to learn
so it's not for me yeah it's not for you
quick question on chris um
online because i've done the online
component yet with the races do you do
can you set parameters because one thing
i do like about it is they got the pit
mechanics and stuff can you do that also
online
yeah so it kind of also generates um a
few different
race style so longer races shorter races
so the longer races have tire wear and
fuel consumption
um yeah so you can you can kind of set
up a set parameters for your own lobby
or you can jump into the races which are
little mini championships which we've
got parameters so the longer races yeah
you've got a kind of nice stuff for fuel
change tires you kind of feel the car
getting slower and kind of a bit more
slippy you know when the tires were
sorry like you say it's really really
good and it's really you need to master
kind of race lines and things like that
that a normal kind of sim based racing
game would use um
but great fun but yeah i i had a game
with a
dealer cult um a couple of a couple of
uh online kind of randomers and they
were quick
the online randomness were really quick
and sweaty
like beta stages and all kinds and they
were flying so
yeah it's a great game
and then the only other thing
i've been like i enjoyed the clothes
that open beta riders republic
when it came out a few months ago
so i've jumped into the kind of four
hour joe trial version again at the
moment so um i'm looking forward to that
game so i was kind of a big fan of
classic ssx and things like that game
and cog which one which one rogers
republic um
um out of packs i think yeah i think it
sounds familiar like maybe maybe the
writers yeah
i'm not sure but not not me per se but
um yeah but that's cool it's cool chris
love what you hear what you're playing
and stuff like that so let's get into
these intro because you know we got the
four horsemen of gaming those original
lords of the realm here at the round
table a little updated time set just a
little just a little it's a long show
why are we not time sensitive yeah i
know it's usually one of the guests
everybody
[Laughter]
they're like cut it out king cut it out
we know you got a lot to say today
oh god no wait wait did something happen
you were gonna stop stop
the difficult game conqueror lord of his
own world and the how of the young wolf
my man lord addict how we doing sir
doing pretty good man uh
what's funny is uh man phoenix point
been beating my ass
oh like i ain't never played a game
that is like i might be going c now
already
because it's just like i didn't i'll be
sitting there i'll be playing it
i think i got a good grasp on what's
going on
and then
since i st i didn't play when that when
they were doing all the dlcs and stuff
on pc i didn't play none of that
i was like wait for the console version
so what happens is i learn what's going
on and then the next damn dlc gets
introduced i'm like oh okay i don't know
anything about this then i gotta restart
with that knowledge about that dlc
it's
it's been a great game you know i'm a
huge xcom fan and i honestly do think
that you know i still think xcom's the
goat
but
there's a lot of things in this game
that you know uh
xcom need to come over there like can i
borrow your homework okay just don't
make it all don't don't make it
identical
hey addict
where are you playing that game at
while playing it on game pass king oh my
god
i have ultimate and i did have to buy
all the dlc oh but that's cool though
but you know as long as you got to
partake first
you got a chance to taste the food they
said yeah you got to sit first
let me let me get some more blondes
i got a couple things to say real quick
one
we'll be doing the chivalry uh
stream sometime uh next saturday so
definitely be following us on twitter
i wanted to say at the beginning of the
podcast because i don't want people
because i know the end of the podcast
normally we announce stuff like this but
i know there's a better chance people
see the beginning than the end yes so
yeah definitely stay tuned for that uh
probably
going off at the end with here in the
next month
me and king will will be releasing um
videos on me and him playhouse house of
ashes nice uh so you know definitely
looking for i think we all gonna do king
i think we we uh
once we get through house ash i think we
will start just hitting a bunch of co-op
games like i want to play dead space 3.
yeah i want to play as long as it's in
game pass
[Laughter]
here we go
i think the resident evil games are in
game pass but definitely look out for
that you guys uh so and you know if we
we definitely don't have a good show man
we're gonna have a good show like like i
the the show i know i needed the energy
i i bought
the energy drink and i never do that so
okay oh he ready he ready
no doubt and of course we have our most
technical gaming lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also the sastradamus the
lord of clarity and lord patriarch of
the iron bank my man lord sovereign how
we doing sir i'm doing fantastic despite
the fact that i gotta work after the
show but i'm very excited about today's
show
i'm excited to have chris here i wasn't
here last time chris was here so um i'm
a bit i'm a bit of a liverpool slash
psygnosis fanboy
bro
yeah we gonna get in that bag with them
colony wars
bro we gonna get in that world
i'm glad to have chris absolutely man so
much to talk to him about i'm glad you
said that real quick um i know first
what you playing and then if you could
get a couple super chats because yeah
yeah i'm gonna get those um so first
i've just just met roy dredd bro
yeah
these guys have they've had a couple of
chances with castlevania they had a
couple they had samus returns on the 3ds
which i hope they bring over
but this
when you're talking about you could have
maybe crafted the best metroid game ever
like it's like wow
um
it's selling it's selling
it's selling
but again
but i will caveat
it's much like much like the xbox in
japan
like where you're coming from
i i i do think that that that title's
gonna stop 10 million plus
[Laughter]
you know it's not even on their service
um
they don't believe in their titles um
but it's like
from what i heard when when we were
talking about it it's the worst selling
franchise in nintendo's history oh it is
i mean yeah
it's a lot easier to to sell the marios
the zeldas we ain't had a metro game in
a minute like they don't really be
making them like that so like we don't
consistently pop them out obviously some
are going to flop a lot easier than
others and and i think if there's
anything that's going to sell it's going
to sell on the switch because there's
nothing else
exactly yeah if they bring them all over
to the swiss i need to bring salmon's
returns over to the switch because you
know they put it on the 3ds when the 3s
was dying already so it's a lot of stuff
doesn't make sense with metroid and it's
always been sort of a side franchise for
them but
on the switch anything sells so
i'm happy with it no doubt
let me let me read this let's get these
chats real quick
all right so we have to start off first
off let's put the crest in the chat for
tyson lewis newest members
we got both boxes in the realm today you
don't know that was one hell of a fight
then we have cedric h ten dollar super
chat hashtag worldwide
oh here we go
yes and we have tyson lewis with the two
dollars off the chat i have to see what
that is chf uh two dollars we chat ah
yes it's about to get messy king david
and i do want to say something real
quick in those don't think i wasn't
reading those games that you guys were
the mentioning games i was youtubing
some of these videos and i was like hey
how did they dance
they went to paige they went the face
yo all of you guys that were put in like
360 games and oh yeah no no no
we're
my friend tyler from final fantasy i'm
like you're an idiot like i grew up with
this dude he knows i'd beat that game
what
they'll do get to yourself then we got
paul afc five pound super chat respect
to the realm so playstation releasing
god of war on pc means only one thing
timed exclusive
keep that same energy and get them king
here we go that's what they waiting for
but never buy this amazing guest we have
rolled with the punch yeah i just wrote
it down
look they they they have they threatened
me on a wednesday and graced me on a
saturday so you know it is what it is
what else we got
then we have the darsh knight oh four
pound 49 pence super chat it's the
lord's day and the lords of world
football just put spurs to the sword
irons irons irons because of the dodge
that's my guy right there love you so
dodge night man salute to him man get
off the rooftops man i know you're still
probably yeah
salute to you brother good to see you
there we go
five dollars to be chat hear ye hear ye
knees have been collected by the king
god of war on pc remember to use the
lotion
that statement on its own is not
great that sounds crazy i love it though
it was hilarious
then we have gameonomics with 100 where
is this again rupees 100 rupees
in india no ps now no nintendo online
but all xbox features are cheaper than
the us including game pass people here
moving to xbox this generation wow
fantastically here this is what you want
to see
then we have booty
respect to the lord
have some bad news me not play destiny
no more seven years be ready for
something else
what's going on he heard that worldwide
talk
he had to come through
he got gerald back two dollars super
chat oh hell the eye opened absolutely
thank you thank you brother
and last one that's what we're on ryan
ginther five dollars super chat first
super chat for the iop happy to be here
oh thank you thank you call it nexus yes
much love scarlet nexus on game pass is
the goat finally hey
real quick because even though this is
not a super chat oh shout out for the
merch we got the merch alert my man mr
joanna dark no doubt he's don in the hat
of the run we got that iop
snap back looking clean
integrated into the store so you could
go get that but that's what it solved
yeah that's been something because i
ain't moving to play those games on
twitter
you're going to love it no doubt no
doubt
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this aka the xs gamer
the prophet of xbox swami
king of the statues who demands nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
beloved end world wide lord king how are
we doing sir and time system of intro
i'm doing fantastic i just want to say
today um
the views expressed by king david is not
the views shared or thought of by ilp
thank you so lord cognito does not fuel
the things like king david and lord
sovereign does not view the world like
king david and lord attic definitely
does not view the world like king david
and our look at yes
does not share these thoughts thank you
for your disclaimer co-signs everything
king says that adequately
[Laughter]
do you know i found out
recently yes
recently my heart nexus has been hard at
work
lord kristen we're gonna have to ask if
you if you know anyone from uh nexus i
i'm seriously trying to get king some
merch from nexus like so if you happen
to have any you know colleagues or know
anybody on the team please have to reach
out to me because i feel the support
that this man gives for this studio is
unprecedented because i love
my heart
but okay well i've been playing this
wonderful uh game called echo
generations called echo gym okay it's on
game pass
all right so it's a turn-based rpg that
is um a quick time
all right so every move it's a quick
time uh when you when you fight you know
opposed to just you know um giving out
food or whatever healing it's actually
every time you attack an enemy it's
quick time
um you don't have a lot of hit points
you don't have a lot of power when you
first start off so a lot of times you
have to fight the same enemies over and
over again to build up
to level up
but the world is structured like a
stranger things it feels like stranger
things from the music to the theme okay
i love the theme where the brother and
the sister is going around the world and
that third uh character that's with them
is a pet like a dog or a cat um and uh
other stuff there too
uh he can talk to animals and the sister
can hear him and it's so incredible how
the quickie things that goes on in this
town and you go from spaces to spaces
and you it's like a fetch type of game
so you need one item to open up another
place and and it's a murder mystery it's
so many things going on in this game i'm
so taken by this game i am frozen um
yeah i'm so uh taken by this game that i
highly recommend it if you're into rpgs
okay right um i think attic will like it
if he if he gets a chance to play it
not as polished as let's say um a final
fantasy but
the game has its uniqueness and it's
totally unique in the way it approaches
rpgs it's like rpgs
oh it looks like um the tourists if
anybody likes the look of the
toys yep yep i got voxels there's a
voxel looking guy yes okay it looks just
like that it's so funny because their
faces they can make little mean faces
they look kind of crazy but um playing
that um i tried to do some trials this
weekend yeah really wasn't feeling
so i it
jumped out of trials and went right back
to my um echogen any reason why wasn't
feeling that just curious
because i got hooked on echogen oh cause
you was on your back okay gotcha you got
your hands right yeah so like when i'm
fighting a boss and i got to the to to
actually almost beat him i feel like if
he was hooked on something you never
would have went to destiny oh no you
know okay so when my friends jump on
yeah they said they shoot me shoot you
the message you know i go yeah i i jump
in the parking lot yo let's do some
trials real quick and then once i lose
twice in trials and i'm really want to
play something else yeah i know i'll be
that bad i'm in that back yeah they they
they look bad with me right now sinister
yeah that's that's all i've been playing
um i think that game is great anybody
that sees it inside game pass check it
out if you into rpgs it's really good i
have not played anything else about that
no doubt no doubt and of course we have
the gaming ninja himself the shinobi
more cognito spreading that realness in
the roman iop not telling what you want
to hear but what you need to hear shout
out to finally duke had some great
episodes with the amazing maddie plays
one will be uploaded today 3.99 on that
last damn media youtube so if you don't
you don't want to do the patreon thing
you can do that talking about a lot of
stuff that's going on obviously 20th
anniversary all that good stuff and then
obviously we had a heart to heart talk
to about xbox communication that's on
ultimate so check that out if you got a
chance last word would you bantus ty got
travis campfire family my man what's up
with this chitlin stuff yeah shout out
to tyga because ty got yo thai guy is
certified like thai guy hang with with
some certified dudes and they be about
they chitlin
you know
me personally
that's not where i'm at
yeah very passionate discussion talking
about these monetization models with
bungie
had to kind of be real about it little
slow spicy trials or freelance trial
segment with me being travis got
whatever you know it's all over we it's
all love for him so people think we get
at it go out he's crazy but in reality
it's all love we just passionate about
the franchise and um yeah after that um
for me it's been all disco elysium bro
oh my lord oh
finally you know what it was off i
waited because it was all playstation i
was going to get it yes so then i'm like
i got this funny feeling that when the
exclusivity window drops it might come
the game pass right so i held out
and it didn't come together
it came to switch
get good at it
that that's
that's why like i don't wait for that
game pass thing because it's like i
can't wait for a game like if i want to
play a game man i'm not taking like a
roll of a dice normally it goes into
the game for whatever reason i just i'm
like this is a game that is critically
acclaimed
that i gotta feel again and it's what's
gonna happen here it's one of those yeah
it's probably still gonna come
it was one of that scenario where you
was like i'm interested but i don't know
if it's 40 dollars right i didn't
exactly i was itching because i heard so
many great things and plus my backlog
was crazy was it 40
no i was i forgot that i forgot but i
think it's full price i think right i
don't remember all i know okay is at the
end of the day probably full price
probably 750.
anyway
yo
i am
thoroughly addicted to this game this
game is amazing like
i i could go i could do the whole show
about that
i heard it was not the best on the
switch though i don't know what's going
on on the switch oh no i thought you oh
i thought you were
yo
is xbox gonna get i thought xbox got
left out and i'm like oh no so they were
like nah nah it's coming you know i'm
saying something all right cool so then
they release and they drop so yes disco
leads them one of the most best voice
acted games going one of the this is the
worst detective and worst cop i've ever
seen yeah he's he's horrible yeah he's
horrible he's got issues he's a drunk
it's great but what's dope about it is
that yes he
has everything is hardcore rpg
everything is system checks and what you
do but the thing was dope about it is he
got his own conscious
fighting himself and talking to you
why he going on so i'm doing the case
when you're conscious it goes like it's
called electro chemistry right that's
your addiction
you see that you see that alcohol over
there it's the crowd
it's the crime scene ain't nobody gonna
notice
yo this game is promoting alcoholism and
craziness but it's so wri and the voice
actor who does your conscience is the
best everything's fully voice acted yeah
everything it is hardcore rpg it is
detective sim now to addict's point if
you're looking for combat combat it
ain't really that because at the end of
the day well to be honest i haven't
really encountered that because my
skills are that's right
yeah my skills are like talking yeah
i was like was it like turn basically
he's like well ain't there really no
combos okay i keep my money yeah it's
not for you like if you're looking for
turn-based combat this is more detective
murder scene speaking of everybody
getting the facts together formulating
the thing look i could go on about disco
legion i don't want to do rather show
enough law and order for everyone yeah
yeah if you want your detective on
it this is the game and you got a
partner here on your sherlock holmes and
watson it's fire anyway metroid read
that and like king said uh charles
besides freelance but look let's get a
couple super chats that we got to get
into our steamed guests because he's
waiting patiently but hold on a second
we got
hargy cheney no no we got that one
already the man who got them horns
just showing some love hashtag crystal d
oh they starting with the crystal gems
hashtag not enough
wow where did not enough come from where
was this going oh that was all you you
missed that show that was king and yeah
it was in his bag and them and house
it was hustle boom and king they was in
a bag yeah good anyway there we go
five dollars super chat lords do not
override the king hence the decrees of
the king must be upheld by the lord oh
great
we will respect the realm when it's time
anything else there we go put put the
crust in the chat for the newest member
of the realm lord charles king
i like him i like that
man just just to address the chat i've
locked my dms again people are sending
me names as games they want me to play
you asked for it
again
no people sent me something like kim
possible what is that
you asked to be tortured you asked for
this yeah you
[Laughter]
then uh once again let's welcome the
newest member of the realm lord bandana
bush
shout out to bandana bush
shout out to him or her
i don't know
exactly
lord or lady salute
we love everything we caught
we got all the business out the way but
look we got to get into what the
deal with the lord to play but we got to
focus on our esteemed guests lord chris
grinnell his video game system history
his journey into game development and of
course what led him to becoming a senior
game designer so many classic franchises
that saw the computer entertainment
europe so uh let look chris let's start
from the beginning first like what were
some of the first video game systems you
had and what got you into gaming
that's a good question so all the way
back to
being so a little kid really so i've got
one brother um so we used to kind of we
used to play off our parents by i would
ask for like a
master system he would ask for you know
he's asked for like a snares or theirs
and then so we don't alternate between
the consoles
so
so when we fir i i went all the way back
to like
so we went back to like bbc so you know
bbc computer i was kind of like
learning with my uncle when i was like
young and just doing like really basic
kind of like programming and stuff he
would just show me how to kind of launch
really
standardized stuff or do kind of
calculators and stuff like that on the
bbc which got me kind of fascinated into
technology and stuff and then that
started to move on to
the normal kind of journey so the nez
the master system then obviously up to
the stairs at the mega drive and someone
i got to pull a king on you i gotta i
gotta stop you for a second
you can't just gloss over that bad
system with that eddie yes
talk give me some some some massive
system games or some nes games that that
that kind of formed you
yeah so i think uh so what are the
earliest games which i remember on it
kind of you know
well
it's like shinobi so in the arcade
when i was a kid it was kind of like
shinobi it was like those old kind of
streets of rage you know sides side
scrolling uh act like adventure games or
action games so kind of
did you upgrade to like robocop you know
like the follow-up role and so on and so
forth so all those usual things
obviously played
pong way back in way back when you know
when it was kind of like what is this
like video game stuff oh yeah um
and then i think
for me to carry on playing kind of true
arcade games
i eventually needed to start to move to
like pc gaming but like really early you
know so going back to like
three eight sixes you know like old
pentium processors
some really old kind of uh pc gaming yes
um
one of the games actually just jumping
back to uh mega drive so one of the i
think it was mega drive it was
definitely mega drive
there was a game called um general chaos
does anyone remember it was like an old
electronic arts game where you were kind
of
i think red like a red army and a blue
army and you just had this kind of
single screen
little kind of like jump over um you
know like sandbags and barbed wires yeah
like either against the ai or two player
somebody my brother used to play that
you know i think he just had like a
little squad of three or something
it was such an awesome game
kind of early ea and stuff and then
obviously
we tried you know tried fifa old fifa
which was like the isometric
yeah it was like
the really old kind of like the soccer
games early on um
so that obviously got me addicted to
kind of games that got me addicted to
technology and i
i moved quite quickly as i said it's
like pc so i used to play like uh x-ring
versus thai fighter you know falcon 4 on
pc so all of these kind of
what were really the earliest
multiplayer games you know so like doom
using like serial cables you know
between like
so you use it like a printer cable
between them and stuff like that
shout out to lpg
but obviously
everything was like a chore wasn't it
everything after you had to plug this
stuff in you had to have like a u.s
robotic robotics like modem and all
these things you could couldn't use a
phone line while you were on the
internet and all this kind of stuff
so it got me into kind of like stripping
machines apart so
i kind of
when it when i started getting old
enough um i remember going into a store
in liverpool so there used to be a store
called hmv which was a big
music store yeah yeah that was huge that
was huge yeah we had hmv it was massive
so obviously in the uh this is in the
age of like physical everything wasn't
it so you needed kind of like four-story
stores for for games music film you name
it um
i remember remember one day that um
there was a group of psygnosis
developers so way back when so they were
showing off wipeout before it was
released on these big tellys in hmv wow
so me and my brother kind of went in on
our lunch and we kind of saw the guys
playing it so we had to go
he started like feeling what the game
was like and so on and so forth um and
got chatting to these devs where
for us like for me psygnosis
when signature started like a lot of the
devs were kind of you know like rock
stars so like early game development was
proper kind of rock stars
guys i'd like ferraris in the car park
hold on hold on we gotta slow you up we
got slower good hope
they had uh you went to the hmv right
and you let me paint the picture so the
devs are showing you now this is the
original wipeout ps1 never before seen
which was
graphically amazing for its time right
and we believed it
not only was it graphically amazing
solved remember i'm gonna be i'm gonna
be a confession call for a lot of card
i'll be okay y'all put a fraud on me on
this um i wasn't
know nothing about techno or electronic
oh no um
until wipeout came
and i was like yo the beats in this
listen crazy
king and i know about techno and
electronica many nights at the
downtown manhattan
i just want to paint the picture because
it's right there this is a huge deal
right and then now you're telling me so
the devs they do a special event at hmv
you and your brother go
and you're seeing it by and they had
they had they had the ferraris and the
lot these devs was leaving looking good
that's like the sony checks was that
good back then bro you know yeah it was
so so there's no ferraris in hmv but
obviously these devs were kind of like
looked upon as like rock stars and
obviously
when the suggestions first started you
used to see
photos of like the car park where
psygnosis was and it used to have like
ferraris and stuff so
like ian heatherington who started it so
here in heatherington and um it'll come
to me that the other guy so a couple of
guys who started it like ian edwinson
was like a multi-billionaire
he had like
supercars and it was kind of big money
then so people were getting kind of big
paychecks they were kind of selling
selling games and so on and so forth so
the these guys are looking like
spreading money around
early
yeah
early days in the world
you might say that worldwide money going
all
right yeah these guys were like you know
they were rock stars in the day so
here's me and i must have been
well
probably
15 16. okay 17 you know that age there
so i'm kind of still playing the game
i'm looking i'm looking up to this and
i'm just like
that was the day where i was like i want
to make games
and it's and it's such a weird throwaway
comment because like these are like game
designers you're like there's kind of
like rock stars here and so on and so
forth and everyone was just kind of in
awe of how cool this game looked you
know the music was pumping on the sound
system but she was wearing the cars
that game is nice but he's driving that
night
[Laughter]
the local bus driver
and he goes home in a pinto
yeah he's not driving a ferrari no he's
not driving a ferrari
so so it was like it was kind of
the early days of it was almost like
music industry as i say these guys were
like rock stars like they were making
and that kind of gave me the buzz to i
want to be a game designer since that
day i wanted to make games um and
obviously the journey isn't you know you
don't just wake up and you can become
one or whatever so i have to uh talk
about it i remember sending a letter
into psygnosis to say you know so i'd
like to be
considered game designing job blah blah
blah and i got this letter back really
nice letter but it was kind of like we
don't have anything because you know
we'll hold your name on file yeah yeah
the typical yeah and i yeah i just
thought that was like a typical joke a
nice kind of bridge the next rejection
they let you down easy
because i've said that i'm saying that
you know university education or degrees
or anything you know which would
which is something that you know game
dev studios and stuff look for now right
um
i don't always agree with that but it's
a way of like weaning out yes you know
loads of applications really so i don't
know why they do it um
so i got this rejection letter i was
like okay well that's gone and i go out
and i started kind of just tinkering and
building pcs and stuff like that so just
play around with tech i used to love
like motherboards and joe soldiering and
all this kind of stuff nice um
and then i got into kind of 2d cad
design so i started doing kind of you
know interiors for offices and stuff yep
um
and i did that for about 12 months and
then i got a letter out of the blue from
psygnosis saying
we go do you want to come in for an
interview we've got some like goals or
whatever i was like what
oh wait hold on you had to be blown away
by that because at that point
yeah you didn't have you know the game
experience at the time when you applied
but it goes to show you that they
legitimately did keep you in the system
and still offer so let me ask you
because generally i know over here in
the states you know it's kind of like um
what to say what maybe qa or somebody
try to get like the entry-level
positions at that time if you could
school us on that
yeah so it would be qa so i kind of
i
i've got in you know guns plays a go i
want to be a game designer not knowing
what the hell a game designer was really
just thinking that you sit in a room and
just go like ideas
make this game make this game just throw
it to people um
so i got this letter back and it was
kind of like
right chris you want to comment we've
got some qa positions so
it was kind of like we've got these
roles
so i go in and go actually well
a game tester it would be cool when
they're playing games getting paid you
know to test games all day
um
so i go in for this interview um
hit like hit her off with the guys a
really good interview it lasted a good
hour and a half um but it swayed quite
quickly to the fact that i could build
pcs
and this is back in
93 94 so not many people at home were
like building pcs you know
taking out these like pentium 3
processors and stuff
you name it it was kind of when you
built a pc
like a little part of the ram could be
dead and you have to like troubleshoot
the hole
you had did you have your static
discharge cables make sure you're
grounded this is that good a plus
certification i don't know where you at
i don't know okay let's go realize
that's not for me
listen attic about that life addy could
do that stuff man plug and play
yeah well now it's yeah now it's so much
plug and play um
so that was the thing that really kind
of switched it so i think originally
they were like okay we'll bring you in
and we'll test games and they had a
decent
20 30 40 game testers um at the time
but obviously they were testing games on
pc they would test the games on
playstation on you know you name it it
was kind of
a a set of like consoles because it was
cygnosis so they were kind of
multi-platform publisher developer at
that time right um
and then
yeah
essentially because i could build pcs i
got brought in it's like a qa tech
tester so it's like building rigs joe
test and pc stuff um
and that basically was like the foot in
the door
and once you're in there you know
you're kind of on the ground and
learning how
development happens so you learn how
important qa is you learn how do you
start to speak to kind of developers
because you're back and forth over
issues with with the code or the
hardware or whatever it may be right um
and i slowly started to get into the
business of game development then i
started to think about actually we'll go
a game designer doesn't just sit there
making these ideas people build it so
game designers like a man manager you
know um yeah ideas creation but you're
also doing like scripting you're doing
you know commentary script or
verbal scripting um so that was kind of
a manager role and then you've got you
know front end devs back end devs
graphics and so on and so forth and
i kind of learned the business of
developments and enjoyed my time in qa
but within about 18 months it was a
position came up for
a designer on f1 so it was like the
first f1
that was coming in-house to so basically
the the original f1s that cygnus was
published were done by bizarre creations
yes bizarre creations
so so those are the guys that built
things and cygnosis published it um
jorah and my kind of stint in that qa
period that's when sony acquired
psygnosis so they come in and basically
when you guys are going to start making
playstation only games you know you can
make console owner games and that
multi-platform developer's gone
you just um for this box here and that
box only and that's when the tires
became round because i'm gonna tell you
this
when playstation got a hold of the f1
license
that's when we were talking about around
i don't know somehow you was gonna bring
playstation in this like for some reason
i feel like there's a caviar in this no
no no um okay that's the first
his game
is the first f1 game that i purchased
yes me too
i can't wait i'm waiting for this
because this got me into yeah me and
king was in his back i had no idea i
needed to play a f1 game until i saw it
in like game fan or egm i don't know
which magazine i saw it in
um but i saw the tires were around right
and usually you get those black tires
yes um virtual racing and all that
you know games you got block tires yep
some games came out with no tires in the
cars we'll get to that later but
this game i remember the tires were
around and i was like i was so enamored
with the round tires i said i got to buy
this game yeah so yeah i was one of your
patrons i was one of your customers
no no i love that and it's and it was
kind of you know obviously sony started
to try and like control
you know the psygnosis tested i mean
controlling like a horrible way at this
time but they were basically like well
we we've got our own kind of internal
studios so we can bring f1 in-house they
just paid a lot of money for that
license for the next you know
that's a huge license
i would assume especially in europe like
because i just want to stop you for a
second because again
what king is saying is kind of
it's so funny because king i agree with
him as far as like you know what gets
you into stuff right and for me you know
one of the things i always tell people
like nhl hockey on ea's gave got me into
watching hockey in real life right
in the states we didn't have f1 we had
um as far as our tv would be like indy
indy racing indy 500. so i would watch
those guys you know about mario andretti
like legend that kind of thing paul
tracy these guys right and i remember
getting into it and what happens is
people are like oh that's cool
but the real giant is that one right and
that's how i learned about that and so
it's so interesting how video games
can spark it because like like king was
saying like f1 was one of those titles
it was like the hardcore
simulation
racing with pit stops and tire where we
talk about like all these things and if
i correct me if i'm wrong chris like
was it their commentary
in rate like that's a big deal at that
time for ps1 the ps2 yeah massive yeah
because um you know we were working so
in in f1 in europe and globally there
was
the the famous murray walker so he was
like this big voice of f1
so we have to kind of write the script
and stuff and this was the part where i
ca you know you kind of learn what goes
into it because
i think naive
naively i thought that you know there's
a few kind of scenarios and commentators
or whoever are doing like voice
you know voice acting essentially are
kind of making or
they're having kind of natural
conversations and stuff right and it's
not that at all you know you you i
literally wrote you know
10 20 plus thousand lines of commentary
and it's and it's
and it's like every line it's every
permutation and obviously technology has
got better so those joy-ins sound much
better even across like fifa games or
nhl games or so on and so forth but
it was a real kind of
labor of love where you would have to
say you know
lord cognito wins the race and then it
has to be like you know king wins the
race you know lord sovereign wins the
race and you've got to do that for kind
of 22 drivers yeah then you've got to
then you've got to do the perpetration
of you know if you want like a nice
little natural sound and sniffers of
know in first places you know laura
cognito in second place
but then
it can't just be it can't always just be
in second place then so then you have to
write kind of 20 versions of coming
second yeah then in second
because i remember
i got like there for a little bit i was
into like heavenly modding especially
like the original pokemon games
so like when i would write a script for
those because i was modding uh pokemon
games like uh making whole storylines in
pokemon like you like it's crate like
you would have to tell it pretty much
like okay
when you get to this kind of scenario if
this variable checks do this script
like
it it was
it took me
months to learn all that [ __ ] like it
was um
what i remember most about f1 was the
fact that you can play you had the
playstation link came with i remember
that oh the link
and you could play and you could play
the entire an entire season with the
other person it wasn't just one race it
wasn't just regular multiplayer it was
like you can play the entire it was like
sixteen seven years
it was it wasn't a jew that played the
whole season no that was mark
we gotta shout out
cause cold barrel
he's an original lawyer he always
listens yes he was the one that got me
into f1 because again the foundation was
indycar racist
in the states we didn't have any
hardcore like it was like none of that
we had like super monaco gp
yeah monaco monaco gp
you know and like king was saying
everything else was like the rough tires
you know pole position virtual racing
i saw those tires i was like okay
and remind me remind me did it also have
weather effects i could have sworn it
had rain effects or maybe it was a later
one but i know the tire the tires was a
big deal but i remember rain like you
could see the slickness of the of the
water on the tires
yeah so we had weather effects but
obviously the kind of last one we did
which was championship edition yes and
some of like the best weather effects
yes because because studio liverpool had
some of the greatest
like graphics engine programmers that
i've never worked with so
and then and that was the that was the
thing with studio liverpool and this is
you know one of the things which is
kind of you know it breaks my heart to
this day
and i'm you know we we get into it in a
bit but
there's kind of this like
there's this commentary in social media
and the kind of like you know the gaming
circles as we say where it's kind of
like
xbox have kind of you know ruined lion
heads and they've they've destroyed this
studio and narrative really if you look
at like yeah you look at the narrative
there's like two studios really that
closed down
the lion head thing lionhead were great
but then
as a you know as gaming as a business
you know lionhead become
too experimental
for microsoft for xbox and the two xp it
would have been too experimental for
sony or
you know you can't just kind of
you can't just make these games which
will you know in five years it may
mature or you know you could do this or
you could do that and it's kind of
and it's someone
playing with someone else's money you
know with someone trying things and
that's what
peter molyneux is effectively doing
towards the end of the end of that kind
of rain
i definitely you know i agree with you
on that because like it's like a
scenario that we have a bungie you know
like let me turn this off i don't know
what i can't hear my notifications
because my headset's on so i heard it go
off once but like so
the thing that
i always get irritated with is like look
there is a lot of times where it is
outside influence like there is like
what happened with dead space you know
visual definitely was influenced by ea
does that happen a lot
debatable we don't really know what goes
on to there but i do feel like we get
into this
to this to this corner
where we always want to blame the
publisher but never want to put no blame
on the developer like and i'm not saying
like
bungie prime example love bungie to
death love their game to death
but they're still making the same bad
decisions they were when they were
without
then there was not activision so it's
just like sometimes you know
uh it's both parties it's not just one
like
it's just like everyone can get this
blank
you know when it came to lionhead
studios i loved that it was fable i love
the franchise but they were on the
decline and it's just like you know
at one point in time people had to have
hard conversations
you know
it's
arguably that fable was it was always
the decline because me personally a lot
of people think they will choose the
goat but i thought fable one was the
goat and to me
they did nothing but a decline and then
they made that that atrocious fable
legends that was the the that was the
end of it you're for that listen it is
what it is it is let's continue because
i do want to hear where you were going
yeah with that yeah so and i think you
know that kind of exists within any kind
of game development circle so whether
you know someone's under kind of
activisions of varela sony's umbrella
you know xbox's umbrella you name it the
problem
that you encounter within that type of
environment is
and it's the same for any kind of
working environment you will always
start to create
kind of cliques so you'll always start
to create you know bunches of people
who go
well actually it's going in the wrong
direction you know we need to make this
tweak or we need to make that tweak and
what happens is then you
you have kind of
senior producers or you have kind of
studio management or so on and so forth
yeah who sometimes allow that to kind of
grow and fester and that starts to
create division yeah and before that
kind of division
existed you look at the games that
studio live people were pointing out
today
we had wipeout we had a great formula
one franchise
where some people still to this day say
joe f1 championship edition is their
kind of favorite f1 game even though
codemasters have done a great job with
with what they've been doing um
and then you've got you know a lot of
people kind of working on joe they
started helping out on um
kind of motor storm games and stuff like
that because there was that kind of evo
studio liverpool merger um and i think
as kind of sony became
more and more kind of
fixated on trying to kind of beat other
people at their own game yeah so
it went from like a studio that was kind
of creating new and unique you know ip
to a studio that then
kind of got tasked with well you need to
kind of look at making a football game
now because fifa's doing so well you
need to look at making like a call of
duty game a first-person shooter because
how how how er how fast did that happen
because i mean back in the ps one day
starting out it really did feel like it
was the wild west like you really could
make anything if you look at the amount
of games period on on the playstation
one and the amount of sort of
experimental stuff and weird stuff you
would think that people just had carte
blanche to do like okay just just make
something with these 3d graphics and see
what happens so how fast did it happen
it was it just you know the
playstation's an overnight success all
of a sudden now we have to start
churning out specific types of games or
was it like a gradual thing three four
five years into this life cycle
i think it was that so i think if you
look at psygnosis and it's it is core so
psygnosis with the with the publisher
developer that brought things out like g
police destructive derby
though crazy ivan that's why
yes such a love for ps1 for these games
good to you
and they and and they bought out kind of
like
brave decision games yeah so they turned
around and they kind of put it on pc
they put it on console they put it on
everything they could you name it um
but they were brave with those decisions
and i think the people in charge you
know like
ian hetherington as i say and you've got
martin ken right and so on and so forth
they were people who would kind of say
well that's something new and
cygnosis was that kind of edgy developer
publisher brand you know
do you guys remember that the kind of
first wipeout post then oh mm-hmm
so it was the girl with like a bloody
nose
so and it was kind of like this game
with the music kind of style and stuff
is going to like blow your brains out
and it was kind of yes
separate themselves so far from f-zero
yeah to show you that this is like the
adult version yes
f-zero grew up
and the music separated well to see
the seat let's say the cd actually
changed everything you know because uh
you know the nintendo's cartridge so it
had
you know that music and
they did what they did with the
compression techniques
cd actually freed up the playstation
devs
to a point where like you're saying the
voice and the script and the amount of
script that she was able to put in on
certain things like you're doing like
you said a little cognito comes in
second oh coming in second slow
incognito oh and coming in
you know so you were able to do those
things where if you're doing it on
nintendo's uh property uh the cartridge
itself is limiting uh what you can
actually do when i saw
wipeout for the first time and i heard
the music
in the background and then i saw the
speed
that was going on and it wasn't 60 it
didn't run at 60 right
but
let me tell you like we got to give
wipeout its roses like that's what i'm
glad you said that king because at the
end of the day it's like
that's the sony i love right like
these risk these these games you've
never seen before very hard this big
budget yeah it was they were trying
different things but like i just want to
get this off because it's like wipeout
was one of those games for me because i
loved f-zero don't get me wrong you know
what i'm saying like i was all that but
you said it best it was like that this
hardcore that just the the energy of the
game and then you could combine the
music and and the speed the sense of
speed and the mastery that you had to
put in with it and and chris just to
give a battery real quick and i'll give
it open back up was um you were part of
what is it the uh was it hd fury which
which one would you audience would it be
clear
yeah so it was hd fiori so i did a
little bit of support work on on you
know some of the early wipeouts like
really quick support work um because i
was in the middle of the kind of f1
journey so the license was split between
the two um i did some hd fiori we were
working on um kind of a new wipeout game
when i got seconded to gorilla games and
i think what happened is
sony started to kind of lose confidence
in you know wipeout became a very kind
of niche product and people who loved
wipeout loved wipeout um and people who
were new to wipeout found it really
difficult to kind of difficult so fast
because you know all of that side of
things it was hard
yeah and and we were trying to do
something you know different with with
wipeout at that time we were kind of you
know playing around with concepts and so
on and so forth um and then i got
seconded to uh gorilla games because
obviously uh guerilla games were
struggling to to kind of get kill zone
two out on time i would say great studio
you were you weren't in charge of that
video were you that was no i'm also been
in charge yeah i'm also in charge of the
cbi
yo
why are you trying to put that one
for people that don't understand and he
knows exactly what i'm talking about
he's like you know no
not at all
yeah it was it was a cgi trailer that uh
they
put
where this is where we learned the
vertical slice yes you know it was a lot
of things that taught us lessons as
consumers and it was trial and error and
this is one of those games that will
always stand as a pillar but i give
credit to sony in this aspect what's up
they made sure i think it was uh
killzone 2
was it was it was a killzone 2 that
actually replicated that trailer that
they put together that the first one
couldn't do
but they actually got it right on the
second one and i commend them for not
giving up and continuing to to make sure
that that game actually got out how they
envisioned it the first time the
hardware wasn't able the first time but
that playstation 2 i think was the
playstation 2 or playstation 3. it was
well now kill zone because killzone one
and two were uh
were ps2 i believe let me
and then
and then ps3 was three but maybe
correct yes yeah please please because
maybe
it kills home two was was ps3
okay
that was essentially the thing that
caused so right to be to be fair to like
guerilla yes i think sony pr kind of
stitched griller up on on that kind of
visual so the reason that kind of
vertical slice existed and there was a
it was a third-party company that kind
of like rendered that kind of on-bridge
action and so on and so forth
and that should have been for kind of
internal purposes only and as king was
rightfully saying it was used to kind of
give
the dev team the ability to visualize
you know what the what fov would be you
know how it would kind of go how it
would sit within the game how the weapon
would sit and move and so on and so
forth and
it was one of the easiest ways of kind
of right you know work with the you know
lead artists and so on and so forth and
let's capture the essence of what this
game needs to feel like you know when
you're up against a wall and so on and
so forth um i think what happened is
sony pr got really kind of excited by it
because it was a great idea
it was a great rendered kind of video
but they kind of put this out and then
stopped this big you know kind of like
captured on play or whatever and tries
to
yeah yeah i gotta stop you for a second
because it was kind of like that yeah
yeah
we we gotta get them for one sec and i
normally don't do this but king is right
and you're right because
now the way you're explaining it now it
makes sense right because
internally that should go to an internal
team and say hey this is the scope this
is the vision
this is what we're trying to do y'all
right internally but the mistake was it
then i guess like you said chris right
so they probably got excited they hyped
about this project they put it on the e3
this is an infamous e3 moment like king
i don't want to sugarcoat this like
they're looking for their halo kills
yeah
they were looking for the halo killer as
that and bro to this day
like few games was able to replicate
that and and the part that was so
egregious was they doubled down because
a lot of gaming media was like yo it's
the game yeah they were like no that's
in gameplay autop because i go for when
i saw this thing i was like the cell
processor oh my god
i was like xbox is not gonna be 368
going to be able to deal with this this
is ridiculous oh the sound that's all
you heard about bro so it was one of
those funny moments now that you look
back in gaming history and king said it
on the money which is the difference
between a vertical slice
and what is actually what you see but
the thing is a vertical slice is
technically something that's
it's achievable in game this wasn't a
vertical slice this was a cgi trailer it
was a seashell
that's what a vertical slice used to be
that's what it used to represent but
yeah companies are starting to take
advantage of that term yeah and they're
certain way
they're they're taking a part of that
game but they're putting all the bells
and whistles knowing that game's not
going to have those bugs and whistles
it's like i i agree with you guys on
like you know back then sony used to
like play around with a lot of loose
cash
than what they do now like they used to
experiment a lot more yeah but like i i
feel like
it might be our goal it might be an
argument there that the reason they
started getting successful is because
they started fight tuning and not trying
to get the halo kill or not trying to
compete in in a lot of different areas
and then you know they try to all right
we
we we're spreading ourselves too thin
let's focus on what we're doing good
uncharted is doing well yeah let's do
everything like that then when last
night came out
when last of us came out they're like
tell every studio every game got to look
like last of us like
good good good i'm sorry
that moment and no no it's cool and and
the vertical slice was was effect it was
born out of kind of getting a game green
lit and sony yes so what you would have
to do is you put together your
presentation you put together your kind
of like key features
you you know a bit of your concept
artwork so on and so forth and then you
sit in front of higher management and go
this is the game we want to kind of work
on and they go we'll tweak that tweak
this tweak that and come back and pitch
to us again so you're going to do those
tweaks and then you pitch again and they
go yeah we like it now show us kind of
visually what it could be like and
that's where your kind of vertical slice
would exist so
they
i think
psygnosis and kind of early sony used to
kind of experiment with those things i
think when the f1 license went
and
when kind of wipeouts started to kind of
burn out so to speak when it was kind of
you know your fans love it and then but
new players aren't coming to the so the
numbers for the last kind of wipeout
weren't as high as what everyone wanted
them to be you had all your kind of
hardcore and you didn't have
you didn't have anyone kind of a
documentary it made it to the vita right
or was it oh yeah it made it to the v
there was there was an hd fury one that
was fired
yeah it was on vita it was on obviously
the consoles and stuff um but it just it
didn't attract like the numbers and then
that's when kind of like sony we were
going through this period and this was
kind of like a dark period and this is
the thing which
joe i haven't got any sort of gains you
know colin mariarty or or people within
the kind of industry but when
kind of xbox get called out all the time
as we said before about this kind of
lionhead situation and so on and so
forth right
i i was at saudi for
14 years so
when i left sony i've been at sony you
know
half of my life basically or you know
more than half half of my life
and i i basically lived through annual
culling of developers so
it became an annual event where you
would you knew that once you get to kind
of february march
something's going to happen
either a studio is going to lose devs a
studio is going to be shut down or so on
and so forth so
that narrative kind of angers me because
i saw studio london get closed down i
saw soho get closed down i saw cambridge
getting shut down um
you name it i saw like i saw manchester
in the early days josephus manchester
gets shut down i saw all these studios
kind of close right and it wasn't
it wasn't kind of like we tried this we
failed and so on and so forth what do
you think they were all off the back of
these kind of like
concept of phases that we used to call
so you know these green lights and they
go
joe try these and then
if it if something didn't get green list
it was like right you need to start
working on like a as i say like a
football game or you need to work on
there and it's and you've got like an f1
team part of an f1 team
who
and wipeout you know so people who are
brilliant to kind of racing games so why
not turn around and say let's do
another racing game let's see a four to
rise and let's do something with that
pedigree right to then go right you guys
need to make a football game now or a
football concert and it's kind of like
well
you might get a handful of people who
enjoy soccer but the rest of them are
like right don't even care for it
why are they then gonna kind of go off
and go we're gonna make this like
greatest football game that's gonna
compete with fifa and stuff and and
that's where
that's where they started kind of losing
their kind of way a little bit and it
was based on what sovereign was saying
it was based on oh but like uncharted
was really good and this game was really
good you know so can we not just make
all of these kind of same games so the
last concept that we worked on sorry i
was just gonna say the last concept we
were working on
was a game called aftermath so we we we
called it aftermath and it was basically
the kind of pitch was
exotic cars in kind of you know
war-torn or or unusual places so it was
kind of like racing exotic cars around
you know war-torn countries it could be
you know weather-torn countries you name
it these these things um
we merged at the time we're kind of evo
and
it became kind of an evo project it
became like you know motorstorm
apocalypse or whatever you know and it
was and
it was then where kind of people started
to kind of lose their interest then so
we lost developers to canada which was
kind of coming in a big
um
and then you get to a point where your
studio isn't making any money because
you've all you've done is tasked them
with concepts and concepts don't make
money you know games that of course get
released and make money um
and that was the end of joe studio
liverpool on the back
cambridge so the uk
which for me had some of the most
talented kind of like sony devs yeah
it's got nothing so it's like it's
disappeared you know it's completely
gone
right and these people are in canada
they're in america or they've started
kind of the challenges these indeed
i didn't have a question i do have a
question for you were you uh
i don't know if you was like directly
part of but i'm sure you participated in
like a lot of like how these studios
pitch games
like could you could you explain that
process is like is there like a way that
like back then like studios knew
like certain ways that they would have
to pitch a game for sony to be more open
to it or was it like one blanket fits
all because i've always been curious on
like how studios approach like we want
to make this game but we got to find a
good way to pitch it for it to get
greenlit
yeah so it's for an intern also for a
first party studio or internal as we
used to say um
you were basically given the recipe but
the recipe
was
you know it was
uk based or you know european-based
directors or managers okay and then
eventually you've got to pitch that idea
to japan
and there must be there was a very kind
of you know there was a there was a very
different
there was a very different thought
process between sony japan and sodium at
the time a lot of cultural differences
as well completely dude let me let me uh
interrupt you real quick so you said
there was like a process people you talk
to then they talk to other people and
then you go like whoever's gonna go
present it would like when you talk to
the people directly above the chain
would they cut like if they like the
idea would they kind of like give you a
way to present it in a better way than
what you're doing like because like to
me like i remember like
what what the the phil spencer interview
where where you know he was very vocal
on if you don't got that go-to person in
that room a lot of games you're getting
canceled like you don't got that person
that's gonna go in there and ride and
die that game
that game's getting canceled like it's
not i mean not cancer can't cancel
something that's not been greenlit right
yeah
yeah and that's exactly what it was so
you'd have a cd producer or you know
senior game director who
would be speaking to kind of senior
management different parts of the
business globally um
and they would be the people who who
would get a briefing to say oh you know
sony are now trying to compete with call
of duty or sony and trying to compete
with fifa or sony trying to compete with
these so these elements are out there
also they want something new and so on
and so forth but you would get
kind of
a direction and where they wanted to go
right and for me i think
you know does merits in trying to say
actually this is doing well in the
industry can we make a better version i
don't think that kind of stands in any
walk of life you know
king will know more than anyone you know
this company makes like a really good
you know kind of statue but this company
makes like a more premium version which
doesn't have like seam lines and so on
and so forth painted really nice and
stuff so i think there's merit of trying
to kind of
do something which is better or you know
a slightly different take on a genre the
thing the issue that i had personally is
you've got a studio full of talented
individuals who have worked not only
worked but they've
created their own we created our own
graphics engine for f1 we created our
own graphics edge of a wipeout but we
weren't using off-the-shelf
engines at one point we were talking
the middleware and stuff like that these
devs have not easy okay it's just they
have a lot of tools in the toolbox that
they can go to and uh very early on
these
developers had to make their own
graphics engine had to make their own
physics engines had to do these their
own things
and that got if it was really successful
that got thrown into the toolkit for
other uh developers in that in-house
sony thing to use so
i understand what you're saying like
early on money was flying all over the
place but at some point in time
the cap has to come on
of course valve has to cease because
uh in one area where you have a game
that is uh successful you have several
games that aren't
and
but just to interrupt you real quick
they used to say that one of the best
ways that sony used to finance stuff
like that is like their big game would
finance like three other smaller games
yeah but that came out so
well no i i was just telling you how
yeah i don't know
that's when the money was flying you
know back in those days uh money's
flying all over the place right stock
market everything's going crazy
now
there's a reason why people were driving
ferraris yeah that's what happened like
this is a good conversation yeah right
no option yeah okay and i'll
space where the company is bleeding
money and okay our big title
made x amount of dollars and funded
these three titles here that all three
flopped
now
the the excess money that this title
made
is gone yeah
it didn't go anywhere in growth so now
you're dependent on them doing that
formula again for said big title
and then you get gun shy in making those
three flops again so i can understand
when the company looks over and says
you know what we're going to stick to
the big titles only because this is
what's making us money and our leaping
people being safe
um
like obviously you can't speak for
everything
because you know you've worked in the
industry a decent amount
i'm curious if like
from like publishers like sony
publishers you know i'm sure you have
friends in the industry too that you
know you heard horror stories do you
think sometimes
public publishers
set unrealistic expectations that a
developer can never achieve good
question
i think
joe
i wouldn't say like sony set unrealistic
expectations for us as first party
studio i think joe some publishers will
focus on
kind of you know the greed element so
you know they will kind of create on the
hand you know contracts and stuff which
doesn't favor the
developers there are plenty of like
great publishers out there and
up-and-coming publishers who have kind
of helped joe indies or smaller you know
aaa or aaa studios you know kind of
achieve what they've needed to achieve i
think
the the difficulty is is as king was
saying joe at some point you've got to
kind of watch the pair strings and you
know
in its height if you looked at like sony
computers today with europe so we
exclude japan and america and so on and
so forth so
hundreds of thousands of developers
across you know cambridge london you
name it but if you look at london was
kind of they were printing money with
things like you know sing star and so
all of these kind of like
arcade you know casual games oh yeah and
i think
when
the demise happened with those kind of
casual gamer markets and stuff like that
i think the problem that sony had is
they didn't have a backup plan
so they didn't go well what did we flip
this studio to so
she only had the balls to make the
getaway which was like their version of
like gta yeah and it was you know it
wasn't
it was it was okay for me joe it was
never at the quality of gta but one of
the qualities that it did have is it
almost kind of replicated central london
in like a one-to-one
manner better than kind of you know
watchdogs legions did so ignore the
graphical fidelity of it but if you
lived in london
the
street or the road was exactly there in
the game where you would expect it to so
you if you lived in london
like you know you guys where you live in
new york and other places you could
drive down the road and go to like the
local store or whatever it may be in the
game you know it was it was that kind of
like one-to-one but that was kind of
sony trying to
create the gta because gta was so
popular and i think sony got kind of
fixated on instead of like inventing
they were trying to reinvent okay
reinvent what was popular and i think
that caused a lot of like the demise of
these studios because it was kind of
like try and make
as i say a better version of this try
and make a better version of that and so
on and so forth instead of saying
actually
this is a talented bunch of guys and
girls who have made some great games you
know can we not sit down and kind of you
know
look at you know what can we use the
talent of the studio for or can we use
it better with other students right
that's why
a chunk of the guys from so it wasn't
just me from liverpool it was like
pretty much the
a large portion of like 3d artists were
working on killzone 2 from cambridge
there was
10
10 20 30
of of us from studio liverpool working
on kilzo whether it was like ai
programmers or you know graphics artists
or game designers so you name it so
i think at one point you kill zone two
had
three four hundred people on on the show
on the game yeah around europe it was a
huge
reason for that
it was massive and i think um yeah you
can't just kind of sustain
uh you know infinite flops as king said
that's right um
but but you had sony kind of got
bringing polyphony over i
mean you make the f1 you make the next
f1 and it's like
and then you're sat there as a team
going why are you bringing periphery
over to make our next game when
we've done a good job of this game this
it was really kind of interesting there
was interest in politics and i think it
you know
it started to kind of see
cracks emerge because you know certain
people felt so of course kind of
unappreciated and so on and so forth and
i'm not just saying that's kind of like
a sony only thing because one of the
things about people yeah sorry it's good
to say one of the things that people
give me
like crap for on twitter and stuff so
me and i could say like
50 of the devs
like we used to play on the og xbox so
this is where we worked for sony so we
used to play the ogx box because you
could body you could kind of hack about
with it
mp3 player you could you know you could
write a hard drive in the box yeah yeah
yeah you're right yeah you can turn it
into like a little dev kit and so on and
so forth so we used to like play with
the og xbox
um and then with anything in life you
know you get friends you're on xbox live
and so on and so forth so
a lot of my kind of friends and my
gaming as in the kind of modern era as
being on xbox you know i have lots of
friends on xbox and so on and so forth
doesn't mean i don't play playstation
exclusives but i
primarily play on xbox right but then
you have this narrative on social media
because i speak highly of kind of xbox
games yeah they're going to say i'm
going to say chris you sure you won't do
this they're going to be like oh he was
a disgruntled employee
so so the narrative was all that kind of
stuff it was like disgruntled employees
like we fell out and all this like
like i was kind of like jim ryan's right
up front
so like i was not called
y'all fell out
if it was something like that chris what
i asked you to do
the the saudi and stuff unrelaxed
expedition but like yeah they do at it
you know i didn't know what to do they
put so much pressure on me they're gonna
be like yo i'm telling you phil that hit
chris up he's about to come out with a
bag it's an xbox game coming this is the
only reason he's talking bad but i
wouldn't i'm joking but
you gotta understand his frustration and
i understand it because he saw these
talented dudes making f1 racing games
and games that they understood
listen when you live breathe and and
work hard at a craft and you craft it to
that to to your apex because you was the
premier guys with f1
were they were they and and and to
take those premier guys
and place them in a first-person shoot
again
and and and then bring in somebody else
else that's the part yeah to do an f1
game i would feel it
i want to jump in real quick okay just
real quick before you go like
we're seeing that now with with ben's
studio like they they made days gone it
was it was successful it was it it sold
well
it you know maybe it didn't review the
greatest right they had them working on
another game that they pulled out from
underneath them then they had that other
studio that was working on the last of
us remake that they pulled from
valley point and that's where i was
going because again this is not to
attack everybody but what what chris is
getting at because we've seen this
narrative solved right where we've seen
it's like what's happening with other
companies right like we feed this
narrative that you know either xbox or
whatever and that you know sony nurtures
their studios and stuff like that and
that that everything is a natural thing
and in some cases that is the case i'm
not going to sit there act like there
was no nurturing but there's also
of dysfunction right and
we cannot discount the ps3 era on some
levels and some of these stories that
chris is talking about because at the
end of the day it goes to show you that
things go through regimes thing go goes
through changes and people can get
disgruntled because if you have a group
of people who are talented like chris is
talking about they're skilled in these
things and they their creative juices is
there and now you tell them hey you're
going to be doing these type of games
that may be outside of their skill set
because like attic is saying the
publisher who are higher up is seeing
the trends that's going on and what's
popular and let's do that right that can
change the culture of a studio and then
you can see people disband you seeing
like chris you're talking about that
going to canada there's well i guess
that's why you see yeah that's why you
see xbox now especially in that latest
interview in my booty we'll talk about
that in a little bit but and where they
they really double down on the fact it's
like we let them make what they want
what they want to make
that's the key that's the key because
when you when you let them make what
they want within reason obviously
obviously obviously there there is i
don't like you know slow-mo likes to go
with my little pony
whatsoever
he he kind of act like they don't even
go there and check on them like
that ain't true either
like look like i i'm
i think that when it comes to i
obviously i have no recollection to this
isn't some inside stuff okay this is
spirit speculation um i feel like how a
lot of these conversations go
is you know they say we want to make
this game we've really been passionate
about this game and if it makes sense
which it looks like for the most part
it's going to make sense because it's
not like they're they're buying like bad
studios they're buying well established
studios that has probably been sitting
on deals for years they're like and they
knew about these ideas before they
bought these studios they're like we're
going to give you the funds to make the
game you want to make because you're
going to get passion out of it you're
going to get a lot of good morale out of
it you're going to get a better product
because you're letting them make the
game they want to make yeah no
absolutely absolutely i actually don't
think this is going to disagree what it
really happens
all right we're going to sign you all
right we'll go but we got a passion
project called bleeding edge
so we want to put this out and we'll
sign whatever you want oh that's true
too
i want this game out all right how
what's the budget for said weirdo game
oh this is the budget and and no but
it was different
it was bold right and and it came out
but we all know that when they did sign
them they signed them with a caveat
we're working on this too and a lot of
projects get done in that manner you
know
what what is it called uh uh
honestly when you do a favor for a favor
right in favor for
i honestly don't think it went that way
i think that
you know they because clearly they were
working on bleeding edge before they
picked up the studio so
i think it was one of those scenarios
where it's like we want you for a vowed
and the talent that this studio can make
in the future but you got this bleeding
edge that's that that's almost coming
out of the oven so we'll go ahead and
help you push this out because we do
need content for game pass and i
honestly do feel like they put bleeding
edge out there to to bleed out but
that's the thing right when you have
something when you compare it to
overwatch which is kind of the space it
was playing in it's a tough sell
right
we played it and enjoyed it and we were
like at the end of the day though it
ain't overwatch right i'm gonna give it
back to chris but these are all good
points and i i think it's a combination
i think you kind of agree with slo it's
i don't think you guys really disagree i
think it's one of those situations that
disagree you guys really don't disagree
it's the same thing but at the end of
the day it's like you know here's the
deal you know prior to acquisition
from what we understand these studios
are working on stuff they had things
already going on right
and then there's the okay we're going to
acquire you like a boxer comes we're
going to acquire you and here's this
other project we were also working on
like for example you know in obsidian's
case it may be you know a vow but they
will already try to get out of worlds
out the door during that process right
and we'll get into the booty interview
we'll get it to the field not to mention
yeah
if they don't let them finish these
games and these and this gets leaked
that the moment they bought obsidian
they can bleeding edge i mean not
bleeding edge uh grounded the moment
they bought ninja theory they can't
bleed the edge that's gonna make it look
completely opposite to what microsoft's
going they had elected right and that's
why i'm gonna give it back to chris
which is you know in these type of
situations right the acquisition phase
the acquired phase like do you think
it's a situation where you know
this is leveraged to the buyer right the
dev is leveraged by like hey you know we
want to get this out the door and this
is part of the decision making on
whether or not to sign with a sony or
microsoft what do you think about this
whole situation
yeah i think i mean if if something's
kind of in the oven or you know part in
the oven i think um i think any kind of
publisher or you know acquirer would be
silly not to allow that to to continue
or to happen but on the flip side
you know to the counter argument where
people are saying you know
the normal narrative where they're like
oh
xbox i haven't had any bangers and they
start the other you know
the usual crap that comes out is that if
you look at
if you take that studio and that studio
wasn't part of the xbox or microsoft
family
then bleeding edge could have killed off
that studio
kind of polishing places or this stuff
the other and
the kind of the alternative and it's
difficult for me to say this it's not me
saying it's a bad game or anything
because i've got kind of friends and
stuff we've worked there but yeah
you know bleeding edge
is kind of like sony's destruction all
stars yeah so and and and that studio is
awesome you know there's some ex sony
studio people there's some ex-bizarre
creations people in there so the studio
that did destruction all-stars is a very
talented studio the one thing i don't
know is whether
destruction all stars was kind of
pitched into them
as the kind of you know sony's rocket
league or whether it was something that
those guys were working on and pitched
it back out to sony um
but you knew that was kind of in trouble
when it quickly became like a free you
know psn game and so on and so forth um
and it's not kind of fulfilled its
potential which
joe let's face it was kind of let's
create our rocket league or let's see
of course our twisted metal or whatever
um but it's it's kind of
you know
you sometimes have to have like the
backing of yeah they're a strong
publisher
to allow someone to kind of try that it
didn't work
and and luckily that's not the end of
this thank you for saying that i'm so
i'm going to give it to you king but i'm
so glad i could say that because that's
where i tell people when again there's a
narrative about all acquisition is for
the most part is bad and consolidation
is bad and i say okay
but there's also the alternative which
which is what chris is saying which is
okay you let these devs these studios
stay independent and they go on as
creative and they have this the all
these great ideas but not everything's
gonna hit and there's going to be times
or situations where that passion project
or that great idea will flop and
sometimes that flop the studio will not
survive so to me i look at it i rather
the alternative of the acquisition
because my thing is at least they're
allowed the ability to experiment if it
doesn't work they still live because
they still got the backing of whoever
that is acquired and that's the only
part i want to say because i know
i keep seeing this narrative like
acquisitions are completely bad
for the industry and especially that
when we got tencent and price group and
this and that no other things coming in
so i i rather it go
with the people who've got the
experience that truly have the passion
for game whether it be microsoft
facility like that
i think it's an old way of thinking that
you know there's going to be like if you
don't have these humongous hits all the
time there's going to be a purging right
i think i think this game industry has
kind of evolved beyond that
so we just don't think it has but i
really do think that okay if you're a
studio that's sort of whatever they
build a model right you have to build a
model for development right but let's
say you don't hit somewhere and whatever
that team is released or shut down
whatever the case may be those same devs
now have the opportunity to make a game
on a smaller scale that they really care
about um in a number of different ways
that
they don't necessarily need to have this
humongous budget to get a hit anymore
right i think the gaming landscape is
broad enough now that you can make
something of a smaller scope and it's
still hit big you don't need that
anymore so i think it's just people i
think it's i don't want to say
fear-mongering but it's just people
thinking that the old way of doing
things is still there right and it's it
and it's kind of this oh you have one
chance and if you don't hit you're gone
and i think that that that is less true
now than it's ever been okay
it's the truth for a lot of studios but
my whole question uh for chris is
do you notice like early on in uh
generations
when consoles are coming out
that the companies are a little bit more
lenient in green lighting certain uh
passion projects just to have content on
set consoles right and you notice early
on some of those games hit and become
series later on like they build on these
games but um in your uh um in your
experience
have you seen uh a lot of yeses early on
in the cycle opposed to mid-cycle when
they hit they stride and they already
have uh games slated uh for the calendar
year for the quarters and stuff like
that but early on when they're needing
titles that they go out to the devs and
you can pitch your passion project or
you can pitch the game that you guys
really want to make at that period of
time is that happening or is it just a
confirmation bias on my end
no no that's right so the
the the whole point of like first party
studios become focused on launch titles
right so you're right on that so new
hardware comes launch titles and
everything gets kind of pushed into like
launch title territory and i think
that's where
to be fair
you know xbox missed this thing so we we
kind of missed halo we missed some
launch titles
to ship with that kind of hardware yeah
saudi have always been good at kind of
focusing on launch titles and then
if internal studios don't have stuff
ready then the third party
kind of studios
etc will start to look out there and say
what have we got out there that we can
grab as exclusive yeah launch title
launch party exactly et cetera for the
for the hardware yeah and i think it's
what did it go for kings right as things
mature
then the reliance on that becomes less
and less so they take less risks and i
think just on the other point of like
studios closing down the alternative i'm
not saying this is a bad alternative but
it's a harder alternative the
alternative is private equity houses so
if you don't get in so if you don't get
snapped up by
uh you know a publisher or a hardware
you know um provider an xbox or sony so
on and so forth then you've got to look
at the private equity market you've got
to look at get an investment in
and that
results in you losing large percentages
of your dev studio or so on and so forth
if you then have a flop
the private equity house has no
desire to fund a second flop
and they very rarely start to like chase
the losses so they'll very rarely say
right well we do we've just lost
whatever for argument to take like five
million quid on that so we're gonna put
another eight million quid into the next
game because we'll get our five back and
we'll get more on this one and so on and
so forth they will more than likely walk
away yes which results in a studio
closing down yes whereas at least
being acquired by someone like sony or
being acquired by xbox or you know even
someone like a tencent or amazon to do
to a degree
if that kind of flopper cares they will
turn around to go but actually what
we've done is we've learned
that that studio was really good at
these elements so the the these parts of
the flop were like really good really
polished really nice so our next project
will make use of
those kind of expertise or you know that
type of genre or so on and so forth
and they'll more than likely give it
another chance so you don't see anything
like you know as i say it's difficult
i'm not saying
lucid is a bad developer or anything
looser there's a superbly talented
developer um
i think you know what happened with like
destruction all stars of course they're
not they're going to sit there and say
well that didn't perform as well as we
wanted it to perform but the good thing
is is they've
probably got multiple kind of deals with
with sony or
another publisher because of their kind
of expertise which allows that to not
impact or not cause that studio to close
down because yeah they're wrapping up
you know the hiring more people and so
on and so forth so it hasn't had too
much of a negative impact but it's not
the kind of banger title on playstation
that everyone
was saying the rumor
the rumors twisted metal right
twistability yeah so i hope so yeah
yeah it was like the version of it
wasn't
the show with the destruction all-stars
lends to uh that title
that title destruction all stars look
nice and it looks presentable very
political title you know very polished
uh very niche in what they were trying
to do
but um i think the
how they were worrying about how they
were going to bring it across to their
public uh
that hurt it if they were a little bit
more
uh strong and and how they was
presenting it to the public i think it
would have went across a whole lot
better because had they initially said
from the beginning
that this is going to be in the
playstation now to get more subscribers
yeah
playstation now i think they kind of
backtracked off for certain things
because they were afraid in how their
public would right uh work with and that
hurts uh it made it look like it was
like i think it made it like there was
something wrong with the game yeah it
made it look a little bit adequate wait
it wasn't weak you up yeah
i'm
there is a lot of like you know uh our
friend colin you know he feels like you
know if you have more consolidation
you'll have less risk being took
but to me i feel like the only people
that can that can actually evolve some
of these genres
they got half their studio making like
five different games because they can't
eat me they can't meet quote
quotas i mean platinum makes like 50
games a year like you know i mean
obsidian was making like three or four
at a time uh you know like their studios
was being broke up into multiple so was
ninja theory like you know to me it's
like
the studios that can actually evolve the
industry the studios that can actually
put a lot of critical thinking and make
stuff that's not been done
they're not properly funded
it and it's just like the ones that are
taking the safe risk the the uncharters
the halos the gears the formulas they
know is gonna work they're not gonna try
anything new because they've got the
formula that they know they can make
money off of so it's just like i'd
rather studios like microsoft studios uh
places like sony pick up these studios
that have a lot of talent that make
especially something like obsidian
obsidian has had
probably has had the potential to take
over the entire rpg market
for probably 10 years but they've been
completely
holed back by finance by their finances
so so in order to make me
in order to pay the bills they would
have to you know ha ha split their
studio in like three or four different
teams to make three or four different
games for these publishers to pay the
bills but now
they can split all of their s they can
actually make the games they want to
make they can actually have the teams
because uh
talent that's it that's an issue when
you're doing something like that there's
only so much people you can hire so you
know let's say that
game c that obsidian was making needed
some of the people from game a so they
had to go help them with c then go to a
to help them with a
but now it's they can choose where
people go because they're the ones
choosing what's doing what's doing it
and i want to give it to before we even
focus i know we go along with this but
this is a great it's a great discussion
and um the the part i want to give it
back to you chris was that you know
obviously things that attic is saying
and the king is saying it's obviously in
reference to the game development stuff
like that and you know getting stuff
greenlit and stuff like that but also as
far as the other thing that changed it
and i want to shout out uh big cloud if
he's still in here because i saw you
guys did a great interview as well well
with big cloud and um
you mentioned that i thought was very
interesting the importance of metacritic
back then
and and how metacritic was really tied
to game development could you elaborate
further and
like how was it you know during those
times where it's like you know do you
have to hit uh you know or 85 or
whatever it is better because we hear
these stories you know of it and and and
i want to know like what was the sony
thought process during these times
yeah so i think um
metacritic was quite important for sony
at the time and i think one of the
things that occurred is
over the years that like metacritic
score got higher and higher so
i think kind of early on when metacritic
became
it's probably more
yeah
and and and it was important enough for
sony to say look you know if something
achieves
you know 70 or above then we'll give it
another shot you know we'll we'll look
out like a sequel or we'll look at this
and so on and so forth and that 70
quickly became 75 and it quickly became
80 then it quickly became 85 right and
that's the part where for me
that kind of joke creativity or that
risk drops because if you really if you
really kind of drill down into
metacritic
not many games will be 85 plus
and even some great games that we all
kind of love and enjoy and so on and so
forth are not kind of 85 pluses and then
if you kind of like constrict and
constrain your
first party studio joe development
studios to say right you've got to
hit an 85 or you've got to hit you know
an 80 or above or so bonuses tied to
metacritic yeah then you start to kind
of like
you know you constrict
kind of you know you can strict the
creativity you can strict kind of like
risks and sometimes
feature or gameplay risks what make a
game you know unique or special or
someone and so forth so those kind of
risks start to get kind of drawn back
you you start to kind of
you know hit kind of being loggerheads
with kind of game directors and so on
and so forth because all they're focused
on is we need to achieve this metacritic
we need it we have 95 in here cause i
got to get a boat
that fine prince says 95 enough i think
i think the biggest the biggest like
disappointment i have with the industry
is i feel like we've gotten to the point
where it's like
who cares about the gameplay let's make
everything look shiny yeah i mean
and i get because like i want to see
more stuff and i've said this before
like the nemesis engine like
innovation like that
i want to see you know ai
interacting with each other like and i
feel like until we start chasing the the
the the shiny clouds
like we're never going to start getting
innovation and gameplay
if you think about it we're still having
similar gameplay that we had 10 years
ago well
at sadly to your uh to your request
you need to have a platform
that can facilitate that type of growth
and a type of experimentation
and i agree
with you
go to gamepad
he's clearly being too much but he's not
wrong right
why did he say it like he always gave
him i know like the king is doing
everything
i tell you
yeah
okay
i'm down for what you're talking about
uh-huh
i d i think def stranded would have hit
their mark had it been in game pass
because that game needs eyes and needs
people to interact with it on a higher
level for the game to actually reach his
apex and i think that's phil dominance
maximus really is spencer's pitch
to kojima right so this is this is
king's come to death row moment this is
you know why because i'm listening to
chris and i'm listening to the stuff
that he's saying and he's watching
talented devs or stuff happening in
certain areas right and
people are taking less risk because if
you have certain ceos and the metacritic
is tied to this and this is tied to that
no experimentation is going to happen so
attic is looking like okay this happens
here
if the nemesis engine doesn't hit on
this a title point yeah that's not in
this area we're not doing that again i
feel you yeah that that it becomes less
risk versus and my point is and i'm
giving it to you is that this is a great
discussion i want to talk so much about
i know we go along but it what it does
is and that to me
because of that and addict's frustration
which i feel him right because attic is
like yo innovation is lost right because
now we're we're churning out the shiny
the triple a the same type experience or
we're catching the wave battle royale
this that third right but the thing is i
look at it i want to know if chris
agrees is that i almost feel
the indie scene
is now
where you go get that innovation at it's
where they're more you're more likely to
see something different and then if they
hit right if the little mixtape dude hit
then the big public should go like oh
the kids that's what they're doing oh
this is what they want four guys
this and that and
then they come in like chris do you
agree and i'm addicted and then i'll
give it i wonder if chris agrees
yeah so i think the scene has become has
become
kind of
huge in the innovator so you look at so
one of my games of the year i've always
said was um joe death store so it's like
it was a joke
a handful it may have even been two with
you know a couple of kind of art support
and stuff like really great composer so
a soundtrack to remember so obviously
people were crying out for that being on
spotify and so on and so forth and it's
kind of only just landed i think last
week on there um
but great game play and it was
born out of those guys
being fed up of waiting for nintendo to
create kind of like
a true zelda you know that that's what
they missed they wanted nintendo to
create the kind of
classic awesome kind of zelda experience
then go with an up-to-date engine and so
on and so forth um
and it didn't come so they said right
we're going to create our own joe zelda
type game it's going to have our own art
style it's going to have our music it's
going to have this stuff the other and
it's awesome it's got some awesome like
stuff it's got an awesome story behind
it's got some great gameplay
functionality and i think
it is down to the indies and the thing
is is and like king was saying before
you know with
unity with unreal with all of these kind
of graphics engines you could we could
sit down joe get a number of individuals
involved and we could create an indie
studio and we could start working and
within
three weeks we could have like a really
good prototype
of a specific piece of gameplay that
we're trying to kind of achieve yeah and
that specific piece of gameplay is
either
enough to get private equity houses
involved to fund it or you decide to
kind of fund it yourself
um or
you pitch it to a to a publisher you say
look we've got this little vertical
slice a true gameplay vertical slice
let's start to kind of work together on
this and the innovation is being born
from that so what are the
studios i wanted a quick shout out to
was the molasses flood so the molasses
flood
former kind of irrational game so when a
rational closed down the molasses flood
was born um and i think they're based in
new york i remember rightly or
the the the you know that way um
so drake hollow flame of the flood yes
really kind of stylized game yes um
cg cd pro project red has just bought
them so it's just out of nowhere joe the
cyberpunk witcher
guys have gone
we want this kind of talented you know i
wouldn't say they were kind of
super indie but they were all you know
they were they weren't triple a but they
were like a decently funded kind of
independent developer yeah um
see did project red comes along and
would anyone have thought six months ago
one year ago
the the people who are gonna buy
molasses floods drake solo i'm flaming
the floods you know it's going to be cj
project red and it's exactly what you
said lord conclusion it's because
there's innovation within drake hollow
there's like
nice little kind of feature traits
there's so on and so forth and it's
enough to go so what could these add to
our existing ip
so chris my question then is
so overall i get it's good for them
right they got a bag they got purchased
every everybody's happy in that regard
now
do you think within that structure
they'll be allowed to make what they
want to make or like you were just
saying do they take the things that were
great about those smaller games and try
to project those onto their bigger ip
within cd projekt red
yeah and and that's the thing which no
one knows so the
it's one of those like the the molasses
flood so you know the guys girls i don't
know what the kind of directorship is
but joe did they have they been in the
market because the people at the top
have kind of had enough you know do they
want to kind of move on to something
else or
because
a lot of businesses are developed you
know and created to eventually look at
some type of exit so without going into
too much like detail of joe urban zoo is
eight years old
and i and i've got people from canada
i've got you know equity houses i've got
bridges and acquisitions places
now interested because it's kind of
survived long enough and it's created
its own product and a set of you know
customers and so on and so forth well
i've now got people approaching me
saying
you want to sell urban zoo don't ya
there's a few things which i want to do
and and this is where kind of game
development is you know the molasses
flood maybe at a point where whoever was
in charge said you know what i want to
bow out i want to give
the rest of the team
the biggest ability to kind of achieve
what they need to achieve without us
being penny pictured or so on and so
forth um
or they've had a conversation
around you know cd projekt red have gone
i've seen something that they're going
to work on and gone right we're not
going to fund and publish this
we'll give you an unlimited budget to
finish that project but we're going to
do a merge just with you or we're going
to acquire you're going to do this
so i think it's it's a case-by-case
basis suffering so i think it depends on
what
the molasses flood wants and it depends
on what cd projekt red want to do i
think
the argument could be we've heard a load
of like negative
stories of how people have been treated
you know making cyberpunk and so on and
so forth and then you think well do you
want to be kind of acquired by an
organization organization like that or
how much of that stuff is blown out of
proportion and really it was
excuse me a small percentage of devs who
felt it right but joe other devs
were treated all right or so on and so
forth so without being
in that situation we don't really know
other than what people have said um
so i think it depends i think there's
some people out there who are genuinely
interested in allowing
a studio to kind of breathe and create
um and i think there'll be some
genuine publishers or acquirers out
there who want to kind of
take control
you know sap as much as the you know
wave riding as possible and and and are
probably like bad for for some
developers but
um so that's where the kind of
the big boy conversation comes when
you're sat down opposite the table go
with you what you want to do about this
um
and i think i'm hoping it's a good thing
for for molasses flood but it's
we all know there's kind of a handful of
people out there aren't there it's xbox
it's sony
it's kind of cd project red it could be
a rockstar it could be a 10 cent you
know an amazon it's they're the ones who
are going to be sniffing around because
i think certainly someone like amazon or
joey netflix or whatever
they want to kind of
buy into success so in gaming so they've
got success in they've got success in
kind of tv and entertainment what
they're doing there but they're kind of
going right let's buy
this successful studio and product then
hopefully it will give us instant
success i think right what happens
is a lot of like
gamers are kind of like
you know
with you know with that acquisition
comes kind of negativity or they don't
know what they're doing so they're going
to kind of steer the ship right and so
on and so forth and i think that's the
kind of mine field that joe these
developers have to kind of deal with
i think i think you're onto something
when it comes to the fact that uh
netflix uh and amazon want to
purchase a ready-made uh house
house that's already furnished a house
that's already running right a house
that is already built in a house that
already has bangers and um i've said
this before uh
sony's final blow and it's it's a severe
blow
if they can ever uh do this and we'll
get to that later on
that that's a great thing because
everybody can look over at google
and say
oh we don't want to do it like that
we don't want to do it like that they
had such great tech with uh stadia
and they didn't have the rest of the
house built they had the small
infrastructure built and the business
model was broken in certain places
if they were able to achieve the
business model properly then i think
stadia could have survived but it wasn't
going to survive with no titles
a broken business model and just good
tech
so i think netflix and amazon are
individuals that are companies that want
to purchase
already done house so you can look at a
big uh studios and the big companies and
purchase them outright and already have
a running uh
facility you know uh with games and
stuff right already on deck to keep them
afloat and have those titles ready i
think that's what they're looking at
this it's interesting i wanna i wanna i
know we these are great we gotta move on
because we go along because we could
talk to chris all day about game dev and
just the industry and you know we
definitely have a back you know from for
more even more this because this is
great stuff i do want to shift focus for
a bit and um obviously you know now talk
about you with you you obviously the
entrepreneurial side you know and you're
doing urban zoo the sports platform
thing and you know obviously also i
didn't get a chance to talk about
obviously your brother you know what i
mean you get a chance to work with him
again and so it's a lot of things going
on here so i just want to know like what
led you to that and then i do have to
ask you this i always want to ask you
this is um
obviously you're there you're doing your
thing
but uh you know
your boys the old gang sony liverpool
man i'm here you know they got back some
of them got back together
over at fire sprite you know some of the
old crew
or you know xbox game studios they've
been looking for accomplished devs you
know here and there a lot of these
houses so like
oh you know look chris what if the phone
call rang
and this you know a little bag was
dropped off
little lucrative thing to kind of lure
your skill set lure your talent
back into the fox needs to wipe out yeah
what if the old psygnosis team gets
together they're like yo
chris we value your experience we love
to bring wi-fi back this is an
opportunity of a life we we heard about
you in the ferraris for the hmv back in
the day
we saw you looking
i think sony owns wipeout but
it can be similar similar but i'm saying
like what if the old psygnosis crew is
absolutely
they hit him up with that call like sony
liverpool baby we we back look at the
game back together you're not tempted
why y'all at it you can make colony wars
wipe out
yeah everything
oh my god
yeah
so obviously when i left kind of
when sony kind of shut down you know it
was kind of like the end of an era i
think i was kind of already at a point
where
you know 14 years dude
do the same thing as you know as
different as it is like making different
titles do you want to kind of stretch
your wings a little bit yeah um so i had
like the usual approaches so i spoke to
kind of ubisoft in canada spoke to ea
spoke to um
a lot of different
a lot a lot of different dev studios
yeah i'm publishers and it was just i
think at the time i just decided i
wanted like a little bit of a break from
it because
i think the the issue for me is i was
kind of like
falling out of love with gaming at that
point because
you're obviously making games 24 7.
i used to be a gamer at heart so you
know playing games
um but when you're kind of making games
24 7 and sometimes you're making games
kind of like backwards so you do you
know you're building the end before the
beginning yes so on and so forth
by the time you get to the point where
you want to kind of release your game
when people are like oh let's play
multiplayer and let's do this let's do
that um you're kind of sick and tired
it's the last thing that you want to
play so
i wanted a little bit of a break i think
at the time you know like mobile
technology was
was was becoming quite interested so
you know iphone smartphone so on and so
forth so
i did a little bit of like consultancy
on some like game startups okay studio
startups then i did a bit of consultancy
and tried to get my head into you know
what people were doing with mobile
technology
one thing led to another we started i
started speaking to kind of like
football or you know soccer teams in the
uk
um
and obviously um it's a massive you know
our kind of football is huge it's in
terms of kind of
fan numbers you know um
different everything
different when i went bro oh my lord i
had no idea i got a story for you when
you finished continue it's huge so it
was one of those where i started kind of
like moving into that era
like that area around sport and kind of
mobile and i formed like a little dev
team
and there weren't many kind of
marketing agencies or digital agencies
that did you know kind of apps and
smartphone
programs and tech and so on and so forth
um
and then it was one of those where
you know
i kind of saw what was happening in the
world of football
um
saw what was kind of missing and how
like you know clubs interacted with fans
and so on and so forth
and then we just sat down and decided to
build a platform that enables sports
clubs to interact with the fans across
like a number of different um
devices different ways and so on and so
forth
let's go yeah so the game changers
football i have to remember
yeah
no no no no i'll say soccer yeah i know
every time i'm a bit i have a big nfl
fan so it's like yeah we're gonna get to
that too
so obviously uh
so we decided to like build a platform
which you know utilizes like machine
learning utilizes
different technologies and so on and so
forth which allows like
editorials to be seen differently
depending on like the personalization
categories fans are in and so on and so
forth so
i've used a bit of that like tech
in a different way can i just kind of go
spire us out of control you know we've
got like
13 or 14 clubs on board we're looking at
more you know we're speaking to them
give me them football club give me them
fcs name drafts
so so we work with like celtic we work
with uh aston villa
fc we work with um you know stoke city
uh reading fulham
there's a lot of like different football
clubs that we work with um
and now we're kind of starting to have
conversations with like a joe in
american sports and so on and so forth
so can we translate it globally and so
on and so forth so
that's why
really for me there's like probably a
next year or something for us to
look at kind of can we do something in
the u.s could we do something in like
central europe you know outside of the
uk and so on and so forth um but and
this is a little bit of an exclusive oh
let's go look into the people
let's go
so i am i am i've had various
conversations about startup like a dev
studio um
and it's
and and it's kind of it's more on the
side of what i was talking about which
we were saying you can either do it with
like private equity houses
so it's more kind of
private funding you know with some of
the guys who are involved in it but do
now in terms of like investors and so on
and so forth they've got a desire to
move into like gaming and then obviously
they understand my kind of experience
and so on and so forth so
it's it's not going to kind of jump
ahead of what we're doing with air but
zoo but i think it's you know it's
something that i'm kind of exploring and
it's bubbling up on the side because
there are a few
there are a few concepts in the locker
which i want to kind of bring to life
and luckily no one's kind of
no one's done them in the way that you
know i see i see them getting developed
so um yeah with a bit of luck something
we'll uh talk about rather i'm i'm sorry
sooner rather than later so i'm so proud
of you because again we we can
officially dispel this disgruntled
employee not since
my boy is getting a bag he's doing big
thing and his phone off the hook king
they they still hitting them up like yo
you don't say but that that urban zoo
bad kind of dice right now so we got to
chill unless the bag is right unless
y'all come with the millions that he
looking for he wants a ferrari he want
that ferrari though so he's not right
not necessarily right now trying to get
pulled back into that right now but he
you know he got some things cooking this
is that ferrari pull up in the driveway
he's like yeah i'm
phil get on the phone chris you know
chris lead him back chris need a bag
he's doing big things out here but look
man
[Laughter]
nobody said i buy it listen i'm just
saying i was just i was hoping i was
like well baby fire sprite might give
them a call
you don't say but look you're doing your
thing it's all good now again i gotta
have some fun with you before we end it
off with the interview part is that um
obviously you know uncle chris you you
got the the liverpool pride right and
you got you know the football club all
these good things now true story you
know i went to liverpool in 2014
uh versus whole you guys play
and i ain't going front
that you never walk alone song
ringing
through the arena i've never seen
anything like that in any sport i'm
gonna be 100 i've been to college i've
been
football in europe
hit different like it's a whole
different beast now it's one of the most
electric things about now i got i got to
come for you though
lord chris
how in the hell
are you
a green bay packers
how like you know i'll be on my tweets
on sunday
and i noticed you jumped in on a couple
of green bay or when the nine is a play
how
is the hell how did don't you got dodge
part of the coast
cheese by editing the chief
my editor chief is a green paper like
how did the cheese get across the water
like what's going on
you look you look cognito you look a
little cardio straight in the face you
tell them none of your damage
no you gotta explain the powers and
green bay's popping
two of the best quarterbacks in in i
believe in your era when you probably
found it and brett favre and i keep
saying the name wrong
yeah
you know
chris
he was his first game man
and and they made a bet and then they
they said if you lose this back
i know the nfl goes to europe now but
how did this happen chris the nfl goes
to yeah yeah yeah
yeah
obviously
not too long ago good chris you got to
answer this question the wrong must know
that so it's so
so bad so my father's been into like
american football for
a long time so
so he was a he was a patriot a new
england patriot so he he supported new
england patriot
back when the old um
we'll go way back to where the old logo
goes
those are the real things your dad is a
real patriot fan of these dudes as soon
as a certain number 12 came over they're
always something
that was good so cool so we were into
american football so my brother's a
minnesota vikings fan so this is crazy
brothers of minnesota vikings fan my
dad's like a new england patriot um
and it goes back i think i've been
interested in nfl since i was about like
10 or 11. wow and obviously at that age
you're not really kind of
you're not necessarily understanding you
know who the best players are or why or
this stuff the other and i think
i kind of got it when i started looking
into nfl
i got into the fact that you know like
vince lombardi and stuff like that was
like the trophy yeah you know he was
kind of like the the beginning of it of
it all and
for the packers and so on and so forth
and
you know at the time my kind of favorite
color was yellow so i was looking like
that
so my favorite color is yellow so i was
looking at all this and then i kind of
read about like history i've read about
like vince
and
i just kind of went right well that's my
team a bit like
people sometimes like find like a soccer
team yeah if they go
back and i have the same way with the
90s it was kind of the same thing i
could do
so so that was it and then i just like
followed them and obviously we had like
a turret
like early on when i was like a young
teenager and stuff we were like a
terrible team then we had like a decent
quarterback as king said um
and we've kind of flip-flopped between
like you know we've won super bowl with
adam rodgers you know we should have had
more and so on and so forth so they've
just been in my heart since then and it
was like and the other week watching
that game where it was kind of like oh
would the field go oh yeah
crosby he was missing all types
oh my god i see you what's happening you
sent me the meme with the and you were
like yo what is going on
yeah that was a good game man now but i
understand
yeah yeah good i'm sorry no i was just
gonna say like from a guy who's like
missed i think only two like field goals
in like
five years or four years or something to
then miss like they were the the two
teams were just back to backwards like
12 14 field goals
you clearly had something something
wrong something wrong about this
football talk
yeah he won time when all right time
whatever
got to be a pillow around here
but i had to ask him i guess i was
surprised because you know to see the
influence of the nfl in europe and to
see the he you know to hear that across
the park that's pretty dope so look we
got to get to it the reason why we're
here those questions you know what i'm
saying the final questions i need that
lord chris grinnell top five video games
or franchises of all time
difficult difficult i think um
so i think uh i'd say one which is
coming out fairly soon so uh vice city i
absolutely love gta vice city um
so i think it was just how you like the
fortnite look that you did in that game
no
i mean
you know what it look it looks better
than uh when i looked at the original
screen because in my in my head i've got
this like amazing joe rose tinted
spectacles
did we see how it looks like those og
screech through like flat buildings and
stuff i was like i don't remember it
it looks better than the original one
for sure yeah
it's it's definitely it's you know it's
not a kind of
remaster it's one of those like cheeky
little remakes isn't it with with tweak
textures and stuff but i love frag city
just purely because you know rayleigh
otter was a beast in it just great like
voice acting the story it was kind of
joe you were living the miami vice yeah
you know what's funny
like to this day
i remember that famous line that's in
that game where at the very end you're
chasing that dude that you're friends
with the whole game and he's like this
is the last dance for lance man
[Laughter]
no doubt
i think that's one of them um red dead
redemption two i think is just half
one and two so they're like the you know
the series for that because i'm going
straight downhill
don't be like that
let's all get his balls off
chris with all due respect i'm gonna
have to ask you to vacation
just for a little bit of like detail on
that i don't think anyone has created a
living world as good as red dead
redemption 2 to this day
absolutely incredible so well keep that
world
yes talk to him
talk
red dead ridiculous red dead lord put
the crest up it's y'all moving you guys
are rocking you gotta put nothing up
nobody putting up nothing in that truck
that shot got cricket
stop it
was the last time you was on was the
last time you was in a party on xbox or
playstation and anyone was playing right
now here you go here you go with the
antidote and adding evidence that's
world evidence
that's fine though
but you're gonna be playing defender
next week though right
we got red there talk to us
uh so so skyrim uh
oh he got he got his machine ready
let's go
we like games that makes sense
trilogy sorry you did the same thing
cause no problems no i'm not gonna i've
seen them you know you know where that
gonna go
it's a great trilogy yes i think
something something really old it's a
it's something i've mentioned before
that's something you're a fan of um the
original shinobi arcade game
which is which got me which really kind
of was one of those games that got me
into
kind of putting you know quarters
essentially into like arcade boxes and
just playing over and over again when
games were difficult and you had to have
a bag full of like quarters yeah
just to keep playing so yeah
he just became my brother now like
that'll be the cover
i gotta see how he finishes this list
because i'm still a little hurt with the
red dead that was it that was the thing
oh okay this is the goat type listen i
have to leave you going
bro
he didn't count
nobody but again
but look i'm so glad because you
mentioned it again you know that's my
heart i never knew you loved shinobi
like i did that's crazy
so yeah the the difficulty again the 80s
the ninja craze the the ninja magic the
it was just for its time and let's be
real that that board i can't remember
sega 16 i know time time
look at the end of the day it we we we
knew at that point the arcade was
superior because it took a while for the
consoles to
what the hell yeah it did i love the bad
system but it just it just didn't hit
their version but anyway
i'm gonna need the uh i'm gonna need
those uh those mods in the chat to get
those people with the red dead goats
you you have my muscles hold your ground
hold your ground do not silence the
realm
look man and then i'm gonna have to have
someone unmod fawn so i can get him up
out of here
those two had amazing interviews with
you as well chris that i was able to
pull for so we got that and last one
favorite console of all time and why
i think um
i think i probably say it was
i'd probably say 360. i probably mad and
probably the reason being is like i i
met
more kind of like global friends without
playing on 360. um so xbox live you know
i had some great i mean i've obviously
given
by uh my list but then i thought about
like you know ghost recon at all like
the og ghost recording
yeah
i used to kind of i used to play like
lots of that kind of like cooperative
you know
pvp kind of gaming on the 360. um
yes i think purely just because of the
amount of people
i met so i started on yeah yeah
i really did say like playstation 2 or
playstation 1 or wherever you started at
and i all and all my games in my list
would have been games that i worked on
you know what king you know what king
you know what i demand king you know we
always talk about doing our strike man i
demand i the adequate fatigue comes on
here actually as a guest
i demand my my my history going through
because if you want to get tactical on
this
everyone's had their flowers but me oh
stop it
oh now you need to be a guest on iop so
we can go we can go through your
elections
i'm not showing up next week i'm a guest
who gave me
oh my god the podcast host please get
this man on your show because he has a
lot to say for sure for sure salute the
addict with the team he's really had
bars he has left on the cutting floor
that he would like to get off begins his
cognitive intro
at the end of the day again chris
tremendous history better
brother oh my god
look man you know i can tell you we were
extra long with you but it was just so
the the discussions were so important
and of course you are still welcome to
hang out and provide you and not know
what's going on you just let me know i i
trust me you don't want to be associated
with this
i'm not going to mind i would love a
mistake i would love him
i assume we're going to get caught up on
super chat yes super chats okay so uh
right
for your camera the very front of it and
just twist that knob back and forth
until you can focus on your head yeah
because they say your hands is in 4k no
it's just oh my hands are full they say
your hand yo your hands is in 4k crazy
yeah so what you want to do is you want
to lean back like how you actually do
the podcast just put your and then just
push
it
i can't because i did something so i'll
tell you why oh yeah all right cool look
let's get these super chats and then we
get the poll or should i get the paul
then and get super chats i'll get super
chat real quick
no but okay so this is what i'm trying
to say do this topic and then save the
super chats right before my topic come
up okay
okay okay okay okay all right cool so
all right i'll do the poll then all
right so last week paul results
i don't know what's cooking right now
with the recent pricing announcement of
the nintendo switch online pass do you
think the pricing is fair what is going
on
i don't know what it is no one said
hands high def face 480p
they stupid
[Laughter]
look at the end of the day with the
recent pricing announcement of the
nintendo switch online expansion brands
do you think the pricing is fair based
on the content to see you know the chat
is di laughing the way yo the chat's
still laughing at the
the winner of the poll
at a dominating 76 percent of the vote
was no
stupid this online expansion is double
the price of standard uh nintendo online
still no messaging party chat co-op
features grandpa is finessing your group
coveted at second place at 15 percent of
the vote was the messi lloyds i don't
care all let's take a stand is a wrap
with nintendo put stuff games dreamcast
saturn and gamecube games on nintendo
switch online they see all date
with the chat they said king head is a
lg cx and his head is a tcl i'm done
it is the last
last place with only 7 of the vote was
yes the market dicks take the value and
switch orders
i'm willing to
keep moving his hands it looks
disgusting
for a premium expansion in genesis stop
talking watching group shout out to all
the lords who participate lord king with
the 4k hands your team is one they feel
um grandpa's finessing what are you what
do you say sir
they know what it is
these dudes try to act like they didn't
know nintendo was gonna pull us they was
like oh nintendo no not this time gonna
do this again it's a double
[Laughter]
tyrol israel said king's hands got the
4k ray tracing up
out of control i'm using the fast ssd on
my knuckles
you know what that is king the the the
the ssd man that's your knuckles and
your face
is right here
your face resolution is what that ps5
[Laughter]
see what happens when you touch it oh no
crazy yeah that's crazy that's okay so
look okay let's give you some chat wait
so wait king king wanted them read
before his topic so we're going to oh so
we're going to say we're going to do the
game
and then and then yo kick shot chill bro
you do it too
chill why you all up in the chat like da
da
you got to fall back fear you do it too
much
[Music]
remember kev from the wire yeah he's
ringing his head that was that cat all
right
having too much fun with that camera but
um anyways let's get into it man
uh the only person i know his camera's
messed up but he's just rolling with
them
right
so look man we got to get into a shout
out to jeff grubb from adventure beat
games beat he's putting out the game
passing news y'all this was hitting at
the thing you know this is hitting the
wires all over the place and um yeah so
basically microsoft's the most recent
sec filing present provided insight on
the growth of game pass the subscription
saw a 38
increase in total subscribers for the
fiscal year and um while they said well
that's impressive gold growth excuse me
without a halo like exclusive it does
come up short of microsoft's internal
target of 48 so they had an internal
target and then he said um microsoft was
expecting slower growth overall for 2021
in fiscal 2020 xbox game pass grew 86
which outpaced the internal target of
71. he said but uh with no halo or few
other standout marquee releases or
exclusive for game pass this reporting
period the company knew that game pass
wouldn't replicate the 2020 expansion in
uh 2021 so this is a hot one that's been
going around the realm you know some
people are like yo the game pass peak oh
um you know what's going on you know as
far as even though there's an increase
or whatever so let's let's start with
law chris you know obviously this
information comes out what do you make
of this in reference to the game pass
and them not getting an increase but
just not hitting their internal targets
um
i think a lot of it's probably um
around some of the missed titles so we
had no halo you know
there's a couple of those titles that
will have increased you know will have
will of course some of those subscriber
increases i think
for
was it it was kind of like early this
year wasn't it where i think um
so jess was saying um so we were around
the kind of like 50 mil mark maybe 18
mil or something like that and i think
there was conversations coming out where
they were expected to go around that
time it was kind of it should it could
be around 20 25 mil
um
so i think
i think the fact that it's not kind of
hit what they expected i don't think
there's any cause for alarm i think if
you look at the likes of as i say halo
was missing um you know
i think
growth is there which is good yeah i
think you you also have to look at kind
of lack of hardware as being you know
some of the reason why you know that
number may be lower than it is because
we all still know people who are trying
to get over the series x's and so on and
so forth as
as easy as like the s is to grab you
know so you can you can quite easily
grab like an s certainly where i am
based in liverpool and things like that
but people wait
people want to wait for that kind of
more powerful version of it regardless
of whether they say they do or not you
know they're waiting for that kind of
like that higher end series x so i think
that would have certainly had a bit of a
an influence on numbers but it's growing
so it's still
on its growth spurt so
so i don't see
any cause for like major alarm
personally for me i think i think the
growth any type of growth is growth
isn't it i think um and we've got halo
coming out we've got four horizon five
coming out so we've got those kind of
big titles where i think those two
titles themselves are gonna attract
more subscribers um
and then next year we're going to start
to see joe yeah even bigger bigger kind
of first party bangers so to speak fair
enough fair enough
lord addict
great game pass numbers 38 but uh didn't
hit the internal target at microsoft
what it what what do you think sir
i think
those internal numbers was
because we've been hearing about the
number for a while actually like that
they was expecting to hit that number by
the uh the end of the year i think that
was
old metrics i i don't think
when you know
when halo got delayed when you know
games internally get delayed i'm sure
you know they uh they they they probably
went back a little bit on like you know
their expectations for this year like i
don't i have no like alarm for it at all
like because if you think about it like
they said surely
that's what twitter told me
i mean it is peaking like it did so well
last month it did so
it did so well last quarter that you
know they expected the same numbers this
quarter so when you when you're hitting
stuff out of the park last quarter but
you only get a
you you only hit in the park then
obviously people are going to be
concerned like i don't think it's a
realm of concern i think microsoft
expected that halo to pop in those
numbers and yeah you know uh
it takes time sure there's gonna be a
lot of people picking up halo at the
gate but you know what's gonna happen
the more seasons pop out for halo the
more of those seasons that pop out for
forza you're gonna see more and more
people get into the xbox uh game pass
and xbox ecosystem in general um i'm not
really concerned at all because these
these type of numbers fluctuate all the
time uh i do think that you know they
they do see that they didn't hit the
quota but here's the thing
they didn't they knew they weren't going
to hit that quote at the moment that
these games got delayed and that's just
how it is but i i do feel like you know
once you see halo and stuff drop
i feel like right now
it's a lot it's more of
let's make sure our house is in order
let's make sure that we're getting stuff
together let's let's try to
uh you know get things back in order
since since covet hit let's try to get a
little bit more on the normal path
i don't necessarily think the obviously
it's a business they are looking at that
number but i think you know microsoft
in terms of that number they're more
focused on getting stuff back on track
than what game pass is doing currently
because at the end of the day every time
phil spencer is in an interview he says
game pass is blowing doors off
expectations so it's still doing way
better than they initially thought it
was going to do it's just i feel like
from the last quarter to this quarter i
think they expected more of an increase
than they got last quarter but they
didn't get it because of games getting
delayed et cetera et cetera and it's
like i said i don't really expect you
know any type of you know uh i saw
people putting expectations like oh now
they're gonna start shutting down
studios yeah
it's over i'm sorry
it's not even out like and i think
that's what you know chris uh said
earlier it's like
i feel like
every time something bad happens with
microsoft
they try to do anything they can to like
really make it bad
but you know when sony does certain
things i i do feel like it gets swept
under the rug to a point are you a flag
that people are using this to fuel a
narrative service
i think people are using this
to troll people are using this to
make videos for profit people are using
this
to
yeah i i don't
88 of the stuff you see on twitter
there's motives doing it people don't do
stuff on twitter people want stuff on
youtube first off you see anyone make a
youtube video they're getting paid for
that youtube video right so you know i
i've never believed in media buys i've
believed in clickbait buys people are
gonna go the direction that they can get
the most traffic from sometimes that
goes for
textbooks sometimes that goes for
playstation sometimes that goes for
switch they're going to go where the
traffic is and this week
it's microsoft dude
so at the end of the day
i've i felt like they had a great year
for this but hey let's be real here
besides mlb the show
outriders
yeah big hitters actual factual yeah one
of their biggest games was the sony game
oh we go get we go get to you sir
lord solve internal targets man does
this gauge like you know is there
increase not good like where where are
we at there's nothing to worry about
here it's not damage controlling nope
let's go let's get it listen you know
the state of the world in 2020 made a
lot of things blow up in a way that they
would not have otherwise
they told me that everybody else is is
making their games without coveting why
xbox having a problem
that nobody else has these problems
that's what i was saying well you don't
want me to say that that game studios
suck they can't do it
i heard that quote
impervious to come in and they can
produce a once microsoft problem
uh
i guess scott award and get delayed
um
first party studio from playstation
didn't delay a game
just got delayed horizon got delayed
return got delayed if i believe so did
it not i know i know thank you for
telling me i didn't know about it all of
those games came out exactly when they
were meant to come out oh no no no no no
no
tell me if ratchet and clay got delayed
because that's the only one i'm not sure
but
but to me
every first party game has been delayed
besides the game that went on
we went from this narrative that it
doesn't affect anything on playstation
side to all of their stuff's getting
delayed
let's get back it's it's ridiculous
xbox game
is stupid
how are you gonna do it like that
yeah
can we play back the disclaimer again
please
elaborate and then always like i get
pigeonholed
the end of the day yes
i didn't think i'd say
so
um
listen listen everybody when when the
world went into lockdown
people were playing games that normally
don't play games and all of a sudden now
these numbers increased
astronomically
as the world came out of lockdown
obviously we're still in the middle of a
pandemic but we're not necessarily in
lockdown
the world kind of went back to semblance
of normalcy and you're going to have
less people just
caring about this sort of stuff right
who gravitated to it when they were
locked in their houses so that's that's
one reason right
another reason is to be quite frank with
you it
when you think about
we've talked about
the impact of game pass and and the
smaller games on the indie side and how
great that is for indie games
we just talked about the big games
haven't been there yes and if you want
to attract new numbers
it's the big games they have to do it
it's getting mlb the show every year
it's getting it out riders it's your own
first party stuff coming out
like
you know we always talk about the big
mac fries and the coke we had high
busters in december
i drink pepsi sir
i gotta see pepsi is good to her yes um
and we ha high buses in december we're
about to get forza that everybody's
gonna going crazy over and if halo hits
we're gonna get the best taste of big
mac fries in the coke we've had a long
time
and
so when you think about that you've seen
those big really okay pepsi pepsi or
someone trying to get us a pepsi bag
exactly yeah
[Laughter]
is that thing where it
when you start talking about that level
of game
that's when you start bringing in new
faces and the new eyes so to that end
with those games coming out they hit
another thing they have to do is they
have to advertise in ways
that goes back to the old school way of
advertising you have this this upcoming
week and the following week you're going
to have the world series right you got
to start talking about forza there yeah
right you have to start talking about
fours today now when it comes to
football you have three opportunities
during the week yeah to talk about to
talk about your games during
one of the most watched events
of the week right
it has to be you have to start
advertising that way again and shout out
to you cog because you talked about it
with maddie over on defining duke i
remember you mentioned the fact like
when spider-man came out you had an
entire train car that was a spider-man
yes and that
that matters in attracting
the average consumers when you think
about like
small games that king talks about every
week those are fantastic for people that
are in already right by the way that's
going to draw us in
the next whatever big game third party
game first part of the game is what's
going to attract the person that's not
there yet and in order to get those
numbers to get to you know the billions
they're talking about
that's where we start to to see that
sort of stuff right
so
that's the stuff they have to worry
about another thing is
when you think about the fact that it's
still kind of hard chris was pointed to
this the fact that
the s you can find right
sometimes yes sometimes no but the s you
can find more more more reasonably than
the x right right the fact of the matter
is when you talk about game pass
they don't really focus on the fact that
you can play it on pc per se they don't
focus on the fact that you can play it
on xbox one per se because they want to
send they want to sell you the new thing
so in their marketing itself it's not
particularly evident to the person that
doesn't know that you can play this
across the family of xbox consoles
including the previous one so it's not
going to stop
on desktops eventually too so exactly so
that's the thing that they need their
marketing their commercials have to have
to sort of focus on that stuff and they
can't do it more broadly yet because
when you think about ex you know game
pass as the app like we've talked about
on tvs and now going you know across the
pond in japan and stuff like that the
problem is there that it's it's not at
the point where you can put it as the
prime time thing right you can't really
do that just yet you talk about it as an
additive thing but you can't really
promote it as this is this is it right
now because people are gonna have no not
game pass cloud cloud cloud
infrastructure right
it's it's not going to go hand in hand
they're they're going to want to
exactly out in as many houses as
possible so they can sit they could sell
you game pass too but they can't the
ultimate oh so so they still have an
uphill battle i'm not saying that it
that this is you know that uphill battle
you said no no no they haven't uploaded
battles because i can't again when it
comes to when it comes to the
expectations when it comes to the
expectations about where they want to
put game pass right the billions they
said billions themselves
when you think about japan that market
right japan yeah is going to care about
those smaller games japan is going to
pair about mobile-centric games japan is
not going to care about the next gears
on the phone they don't really care
about that
it's not going to matter to them as much
so
they have to focus the product for the
region and i think that they're still
working on that so in a lot of ways
right no exactly
they're making strides there they're
doing that there so my thing is this my
thing is all the games numbers what
they're increasing yeah all these
numbers do some crazy stuff
right i don't
that we've been doing iop
i honestly don't think this this week he
gonna be too much i could already
i told you i gave you the video
we can't see your face because it's
gonna be worth it
continue so end of the day and overall
not a lot to worry about they do have
things it's it's been it's the thing
we've always talked about
they need to continue to grow they said
they are going to grow because they need
content for game pass 38 in growth do
you always growth okay always growth but
it look at it under the microscope okay
what microscope the microscope of
everybody's in their house
like so tell me this all right
so so this is the thing right they
probably underscoped in terms of their
they underscope because
they blew past that number in 2020 right
yeah
they're under scope now right so
they were always going to do a very old
number you ain't gonna take that
from last year and put it on this year
why would you
exactly when you talk about these
numbers
right this isn't in the early 2000s of
rollover minutes from eighteen teams
okay
so we okay okay just so the chat knows
king is trying to spin something and
if you're in it and if you're dumb
enough to understand
you see what he just did he put you all
on defense i'm just saying
y'all looking for a phantom kick that
ain't gonna show up cause he just told
y'all if y'all dumb enough how he gonna
call you dumb like i'm just saying what
he's trying to do let him finish let him
finish and then kick you enlightening
you yes right now
i'm just saying that there are numbers
that are obvious
which indicated
that they
they had to underscore because they
overscoped last year that's it
that's all okay that's all they did grow
they did grow but i i don't think we're
gonna see that 30 million you would
predict
somebody else said it was there i don't
know what i'm saying i'm just saying
like and they don't count if they hit 30
million holiday next year
when another ceo says didn't we hit 30
okay another another ceo so my words he
ain't worried about xbox
he worried about grand theft auto let's
go here we go
listen listen
the camera's on him right now he ready
he's like we can't see he got here we go
here we go here it goes the lord of gay
fans and xbox the prophet is speaking
okay
look like walter mcgowan
[Laughter]
let's go you got to talk like godfather
man
a lot of times dudes forget
in this team i don't like your voice you
gotta know
when it's your turn at back
seems that you don't know this
what's up don't know you said our
biggest [ __ ]
was 80 something
no first party titles
and the growth yeah 38
no first party titles that's true that's
true
we doing this all nations
i knew it was
[Music]
naturally
this is organic here
what you're not understanding is you're
seeing a phenomenon
these dudes have put out first party
first party
so just to clarify real quick
you're saying they're shooting blanks
and still shooting
what i'm saying is
the fear mongering those are afraid
when the dudes show up when when the
guns come out
when they start
busting they can't handle it
because in our year when we didn't have
any first party titles
it's eighty-four percent was in
skyrocket was astronomical they was
going crazy upstairs like what's going
on
delay that halo we don't need it
that's what they said internally we've
been wrecking them without it why why
why shoot a gun
when you're winning the fight
so you saying they don't need to bring a
gun to a knife fight because they
already wouldn't
listen they molly whopping them all over
the block
38
you know what they said that's not good
enough that's not good enough
our internal
said we wanted 48.
and somebody had the nerve to sit there
and say uh microsoft i think they peaked
i didn't go peak and they ain't even
shoot yet
so again
this stuff is spun by people that are
terribly afraid
of forza
halo oh and the rest of them dudes are
showing up later
so when it happens
and then it skyrockets right back up
because like you said to your own words
big titles
tend to push those numbers up
it was no big titles and those numbers
was going up
so what happens when those big titles
show up and your prophecy comes true
is it 200 percent
will that get you over here
what do we need to have you over here
that's all i need what are you convinced
hell no
now guys
if y'all like that
it's about oh i know it's about to go
crazy a little bit so put on your
wetsuit
i know
i i i want you to tweet this out i want
you to pass this on to what you're
almost there we always let you get my
balls and then we could move on i gotta
get chris out of here because he's he's
got sticks he's got to do that that man
got a lot of bags people call his phone
is hot right now so we got it we got to
make sure we get i don't want to be
associated with this yeah he's got we
got to protect him we don't want to mess
up future bags for about what king is
about to do
what we're doing chris is we're going to
let you take the back door before you
before we get out this was not a part of
what's about to happen so look real
quick um i see
i see what chris has said i actually do
agree i think um i do agree with this
over the sense that um
you know the triple a first let's get
out there
growth is good right we're going to get
this all right growth is good if they
were to say yo
bro ain't that much movement i mean i
took it yeah then it's like okay you
know you got to start to reevaluate
things it's early right but at the end
of the day yes
they had internal targets but like shout
out to ace it was in the chat game on
daily i know we saw him in there it's
just that like
internal targets
if you don't hit an internal target when
you have growth
that's not the end of the world that's
that if you still have growth but you're
like yo i was hoping we was going to get
this right and you don't hit it you know
what it is it's like we got 70 but not
100 yeah it's like okay cool but you
still got growth now if it's trending
the other direction then you got to work
but i do agree with solve with this
which is that you know the halo part
the delay during that quarter was was
probably factored in into what they
thought that their internal target was
that doesn't hit the the window now we
get in that later year top of the year
very top-heavy right mlb the show like
king and saying outright is like king is
saying
that hits right and at the end of the
day what it proves is you got all these
great games in the service this is what
solve is right on this part you got
these great great games in a series for
people who already in so when king is
doing his yo i played this i played that
it's like you're getting these gems you
didn't even know about because you're
already in but to saw's point instead in
the sense that you need the triple a to
attract the new guy the guy that's going
to be like yo i gotta get game pass
because i was fronting and now you got
this yeah get it get it it just real
quick it's just like how we use it in
consoles like look like sure that the
third party stuff's good you know the
second part is just good but you need
those console sellers like you need
those game passes yes you need to bang
it because here's the thing what happens
with this with the bangers is just what
king is saying in the sense that
mlb the show is now looked at as an xbox
game
right
outriders is now looked at as an xbox
game
you you you change the consciousness you
change the mindset that it's like yo i
gotta have it and looks at the end of
the year i think it will shape up better
for them obviously we got back for blood
right now a nice big game age of empires
the next month nice big game forza
horizon nice big game and of course halo
infinite to really close the show why
does kid get water a nice big game so at
the end of the day i think in my opinion
it's my guess is that
they will then start reporting it
after because they're expecting big
growth for this next half people most
likely are really gonna subscribe and
dive into it okay
they're not gonna report well i mean
whenever they do whenever they but i do
feel they just won't they will let other
ceos let the numbers slip out
and they will look at
them can we talk about this backstage
don't put the minute down but last time
i spoke i said 18 now
he definitely is holding the line on the
public 18 but look we gotta get the
legend out of here because again he
stood up he rocked with us for so long
the legendary chris cornell
put your damn hands together urban zoo
one of the legends in game development
you know i i really want to give you
your roses brother because so many of
the games that you were a part of was
part of the reason i fell in love with
sony like though
those games are near and dear to me f1
was near and dear to me as far as um car
simulation racing i remember the pit
stop mini mechanic game and you know
like just little i always respected the
game that did pit stops i don't know why
i just thought it was a cool thing
because they really tried to get the
simulation aspect the tire damage like
like king said the round wheels wipeout
is my heart you know the fact that you
worked on that you know killzone you
know you were part of that you were in
the room you know what i'm saying doing
these things and just to see your
journey and game dev and obviously your
great new platform so please tell the
fine people where they can find you what
else you got going on sir
yeah no thanks
it's obviously amazing to be on the show
with you guys and the rest of the lords
i have much respect and much love for
for all of you guys you know what you do
um
i like uh obviously the way you kind of
report things you know there's there's
there's balance and there's kind of you
know fun with it as well you know
there's loads of respect for what you
guys do and i think uh everyone out
there kind of respects you all as well
so thanks for having me it's been
brilliant you know obviously love to
come back on again definitely oh
definitely um
and yeah just in the usual places really
so cj grinnell on uh twitter i'm always
on there always off for a conversation
joe if anyone wants to
so they could dm me any time people
asking me questions industry questions
and stuff i'll always try to answer as
much as i can um
and then yeah primarily on joe xbox or
hard times uk so everybody wants to kind
of hit me up i'm normally at a party
with like dealer or daddy
king popped in the other day and stuff
like that so
we're always having a good laugh in
there and playing games so yeah just
hit me up any time obviously
always around for playing some games and
stuff and yeah it's been a pleasure to
be honest thanks a lot for having me oh
absolute pleasure brother absolute
pleasure king's going to say something
and then i'm going to say before i give
it to attic
we couldn't even talk about the chat
that we was having because we was out of
control
uh f1 i never thought that i was going
to purchase an f1 game and i purchased
that game like i said it was striking in
what y'all did uh you probably didn't
notice it or it probably wasn't uh a
thing for you because y'all was going
for perfection but it was it actually
resonated with me and then to have uh
you know um wipeout come out to and in
all sense that was sony's f-zero uh
counterpart or killer you know killer
app uh
and you are a part of that and then you
know the kill zone um you are part of
pillars in sony's history that are
fantastic and that uh built me as a fan
yes so to be able to jump in a party
when she would
talk and stuff like that actually blows
my mind every day this stuff blows my
mind you're down to earth for a humble
dude and uh like i said i don't want you
around with what i'm about to do
we try to protect you
i'll keep it i'll keep listening and
obviously i don't like joe i'd never
like to just kind of like drop out i
don't know they're still going well
you're good you're good you're good
i appreciate all of you guys yes please
do you think attic soft just said you
have goodbyes to chris before yeah man
yeah real quick i mean honestly the same
thing like for me the playstation one is
one one of the most risk-taking consoles
of all time like it just there's so much
crazy stuff on there and to know that
you're part of it and to see it grow
from what it what it was to what it is
now with the good and the bad um it's
you're just an amazing person to have
all the masks i wish you all success and
please come back and uh tell us when
you're making uh a new game yes
your goodbyes to chris
i appreciate you coming on chris but i
like doing the most uh than anything is
i like getting developers on so we could
sh so we could shut up the uh
the the arms so we could educate the
fake narrators
yeah
because that's that's the biggest thing
i don't like is like it like you know
when i speak on stuff i always make it
very clear like i don't know nothing
about that franchise i don't know
nothing about that process
but one thing that annoys me is people
acting like they know you know what's
going on
they they like oh this this shouldn't be
that hard oh when did you get it uh when
did you learn out of gold
mm-hmm
preach brother now look it's chris enjoy
your sunday brother we will bring you
back an absolute pleasure the legendary
chris grinnell you will never know
because you are about to laugh and
appreciate yourself have a good one
brother
appreciate you all thanks so much for
being awesome as well
brother you have a good one
peace cheers
so um you want to get these super chats
yeah let's get these
let me go get a bathroom break because i
know it's better oh you look clear
clear king
oh you're getting real close to the mic
that's what it is he's moving up that's
moving up he's moving up you know he he
wants to be really
all right hold on a second hold on a
second
gotta run it back just a little bit
did it
okay this is the funny one
he's about to for some reason i feel
like he's about to turn that camera on
to like a new wardrobe
[Music]
we got yeah i have a feeling that he's
gonna come out looking like cradles so
we will see um
[ __ ] 8127. five dollar super chat
great show guys a must-watch sunday
appointment i want to open a food truck
that serves hispanic style breakfast i
will name it mama
hey yeah that that that is uh you got to
have something sold their name uh named
crystal d too okay crystal d and mama's
werewolves that's that
wow and then we got pina again five
dollars in the chat after fable is a hit
playground game studio league becomes
head of europe booty head of north
america kojima head of the east and phil
spencer dominus of all
okay okay
then we got big mad mo remember for one
year we uh lord bronzo i guess just give
a big shout out to big mad mo i know big
man moe was the winner of our xbox one
back in the day no doubt
then we got the night beard with the ten
dollar super chat i can't listen live i
download to listen when i start my route
thanks for making the first four hours
of my deliveries entertaining i'm also
delivering more tissues this week than
usual
[Laughter]
big cloud gave me five dollar super chat
we in here salute to the iop fam and
welcome back to the realm chris gurnell
yeah i lost count how many times i've
worn these frauds on was god of war was
going to pc
then we got kids eight dollar super chat
chasing trends instead of mastering
their own craft and creating their own
new concepts reminds me of ubisoft with
x defiant and ghost recon front line yes
very generic games
um
we got bandana bush
this convo is fire chris is a wealth of
knowledge thanks for the entertainment
fellas glad i could finally catch a live
episode and join the realm and we got
bandana bush again
[Music]
i'm a package fan in bear country go
pack go ah
dude then we got the flame log net zone
the flame remember for one year lord
bronze he said oh god
what did i wake up to king all up in
that camera anyways i for one welcome
worldwide gym because i can play god of
war on my pc in january i will be
playing it again on my steam deck that
is for sure
um then we got it's my easy with the ten
dollar super chat
since all playstation first party are
coming to pc slowly but surely i
officially announced that the
playstation box has devalued and no more
need to
i
buy
mind waiting six months to play it on pc
yeah it might be onto something
okay okay
then we gotta feel like he's about to
come out with that camera doing
something something about to happen i
could already tell
face paint watch that's really good
there we go
king one supreme 5 check can't wait for
day and date so i can get rid of my
playstation 5 jesus christ shouts to the
goat gym and my baby next mixes
this is true
there we go then we got tony bryant
shout out to tony bryant member for one
year strauss has already 30 mil that's
why san andreas is in game past day one
mm-hmm
yo slow and stupid lord bronze i'm
waiting for king to put some face in his
4k ray trace hands and give him the kiss
on the cheeks
[Music]
[Laughter]
then we got splendiferous bringing the
heat lord stop eating what is a jimmy r
pie thin on top and greasy out that's
that's
yo pause
that we got to play difference again two
dollars look at that non-believers eat
last sob no gravy on your meat sir
paul's another
[Laughter]
i have to assimilate completely that's
crazy that's
yo this is after i just finished picking
up xbox and i say i'll say one thing
it's over it's over there yeah one thing
somebody
the 48 target was set high to push the
executives to make that happen the tops
of microsoft will do what they need to
make the next target yeah they got to
keep getting them big third parties
that's what they got to do yes sir all
right all right anybody else super chat
while we're jd gamer lord bronze thank
you my brother then we got smitty smith
remember for 21 months wow shout out to
jim ryan and the whole damn slate coming
to pc at the book of acts
yeah what else we got here
yeah we're caught up we're caught up all
right so before we get this let me uh
set this thing up because yeah
that's all i would say eloquently y'all
know what we're here for
[Laughter]
y'all know what we're here for so um
yeah i'm gonna set it up y'all santa
suny santa monica studio
uh god of war launches on pc january 14
2022
with thrill this is from grace um the
senior community manager of santa monica
studios or blog or playstation so we are
thrilled to announce that god of war
2018 will be coming to pc us kick
laughing or january 14th all of us at
santa monica studios have been humbled
by the immense amount of support and
passions for the god football series
have been shown the latest chapter of
kratos story since release as of august
2021 19.5 million copies of god of war
on playstation 4 has been sold and
though we can't wait to share that
experience with a whole new group of
players on pc and the final thing they
say well one of the final things our
primary goal when bringing godwater pc
was to highlight the exceptional content
the team created and leverage the
powerful hardware that the platform
offers to create create a uniquely
breathtaking and high performance
version of the game you'll be able to
enjoy the full potential of our
cinematic no cut camera as it follows
cradles and entries across the trails
against the realms with the option of
true 4k resolution on supported devices
and unlocked frame rate so clearly
this has set twitter on a blaze there's
been a lot of talking uh i think king
has a lot to say so i will shut up
because i don't know what's about to
happen but this is
king is ready to talk y'all what's going
on okay hold on a second well a lot of
you frogs
was out here talking about you know
what's good for the playstation brother
we don't know what's i'll tell you
what's good for you
i tell you you're not enough
21 million sold
don't get me a yacht
i'm the captain now
okay yo why are you looking at me
how i say no more dance moves no more
band-aids for you guys
rip it off
day and date coming soon i told you
first thing i want this playstation 5
worldwide
i want all the games everywhere
tell me
i'm going to chainsaw
excuse me jamaican jim oh
dude are you implying that because a lot
of people be i'm first of all i'm so
glad you could make ilp today
my question to you jamaican gym right is
that you know a lot of the sony fanbase
really felt upset they felt you betrayed
that that that they thought they were
annoying you should have brought the
game
you should have brought the game
i did my job
i sold 124 million
yo yo
jimmy your jimmy jimmy man jimmy i got a
question for you jimmy talk to me like
the the chainsaw jimin
was you telling blaze to cut his his
playstation in the house say this people
say a lot of things in the street the
street hear you
you don't think i hear you
you know what they say when i'm on
facebook
like if you were to to to give a speech
to someone cutting his playstation in
half who what would that speech sound
like jimin don't worry about it we got a
we got a pc for you
go on
take it down take it down this weak
sauce anyway
we have a pc for you
where you can link this thingy right
here
you can blow into your controller
because you like to blow into the
controller
it has heptic feedback i don't know what
it is because i don't play games okay
okay jimmy jimmy jimmy i heard you like
it
but but jimmy you all
just to clarify jimmy do you have to pay
the ten dollar hectic feedback on the pc
no no no no
listen i'm going to give him my old game
for 50 bucks
i'm going to give you
an old game that you can buy right now
for 20 dollars for 50 bucks for jimmy
did you make a gym right but but my
question is your problem but is it
because phil spencer's putting his games
everywhere with the xbox like you feel
that you have to do are you upset that
you don't feel that you're getting
enough first party support from the
exclusive camp of playstation users i'm
upset because feel dominance maximus are
really specific
hold on hold on hold on hold on we gotta
bring you back we gotta bring it back
again
guys try to stop me
i am the captain
you can't stop me
i'm upset that phil dominance maxim is
really expensive got a 50-foot boat
so right now i put my 45-foot boat yacht
on pre-order for january because i got a
wall coming out
it's a new game for you guys hey
you guys got pc
you got pc
i got god of war coming for you
a lot of guys said
only stuff like horizon and stuff like
that thing like that no man i want the
whole catalog
everything i'm trying to be everywhere
i notice
why does phil have a yacht
this game passed and the man said day
and day
he said billions of people
i can't even get the 124 million to buy
my games so
jimmy just just questioned jimmy
are you jealous of phil maximus
dominance i don't know man you have to
explain that one to me are you jealous
of phil is that what's going on do you
want no man we have we have we have
better ips man
we have better ips we have better games
my question is how come they don't
support me
i made it the most profitable
so if i make it profitable for you why
don't you want to eat
i mean i make the food very good lots of
curry
lots of ginger beer
i when you come over to eat at jimmy's
house everything is perfectly cooked man
jimmy
i i just so just to be clear you know
your reasoning
from for putting the playstation library
on multiple devices is because you're
not satisfied you you know i got nixes
that's why
cause i got nixon you thought i was
buying nexus for joke
oh you you got tired of playing with you
you world wide gym it's not for play
play
all right
you're not gonna play with me i got
nixon's because you guys didn't support
me i had to go out and get nixon you
know what they said so i got your back
jimmy
it's a worldwide gym worldwide gym all
right what i want you to do is i want
you to address your fans
to to explain to them why you putting
all your stuff worldwide on everything
all right let me let me let me log in
and log it there it goes you see because
i'm gonna stop you i'm a preemptive
worldwide gym
dance move jim
would have been nice with you easy
no more easy for you guys
this game they talking about oh is it
old game no you're taking your beloved
you're taking it beloved and i'm putting
it over there why because you don't
respect it it's a devalue i see money
over there
i see money
you're not giving me no money i can sell
it for 50 bucks the same game i sell to
you for 20. are you crazy i can't win
they need me i need them yes yes i got
you okay i think i think we got it i
think we got it now i'll be no i don't
[Laughter]
i mean look you know at the end of the
day you get hacks off yeah so i i just
need you to say
feel to feel dominance maximus over it
you i need you to say as only you can
say it
bill dominus maxim is really a spinser
got a 50-foot yacht and i want to know
how and i figured it out this game's on
pc man
i'm there too so
final question uh jamaican
is it gonna stop here is it is do you
have plans for mobile and cloud and
because a lot of people you know ben
told people i'm going to the phones man
i've i've partnered with microsoft for
their zur service man
what are you crazy
i'm trying to take over
i got rid of japan
hi carol i'm afraid of holiday europe
i made it the most profitable gotcha we
need the pc the pc need us
our ips will live good over there
all right so we we got you know we got
the word straight from i'm so glad you
could be you guys that doubted me
it's for all of you
i told you
okay okay i i get that man we we got
jimmy here we got jimmy i want to pick
jimmy brady i want to ask him
one question dance move jimmy you like
to hit more dance boys
yes what is
i want the exclusive right now what's
that next game you bringing over to pc
to get your four
but if you want to reach the widest and
broadest crowd don't you think the next
one coming over should be a a certain
little web swinger
oh man no man we're gonna do that no no
no that's not happening
they shut them down again
we're not going to bring over spider-man
just yet
we got to ease them in so i want
i want these rockets
money okay ssd
okay look we got i'm glad we got clarity
but shout out to pong so extra special
shout out for the exclusive interview
for the jim ryan he's the iop doing
bigfoot hold up hold up
okay anyone in the chat this is a skit
don't be going
don't around that you're right but look
we got to get our balls off because
clearly we're so thankful that jim ryan
was able to show with jim ryan
listen man that is a dream interview i'm
so glad we were able to put this on our
bucket list that we were able to do this
you know
we get labeled sometimes
but at the end of the day we get so many
execs to come on the show and that is
very important so look let's get to it
uh addict
the day has come you know um we've been
through this attic you know me and you
we've been saying it for a while we have
randon
you know he got killed when he said it
also here
so um well yeah what do you think man
that it it's it's uh official and sony
actually tweeted it and put the blog
post out what's your feelings are the
god of water pc
i told them yes i mean right once again
man i'm right everyone else wrong like i
said for the longest your game's going
on they [ __ ]
man i need to stop it i need to stop it
look but we have i you know jim ryan's
gone now so you know jimmy gone so look
jimmy everyone knew this was gonna
happen anyone that knew that didn't
think this was gonna happen you just
wasn't paying attention you know well
and now since we had lord jimmy on the
podcast that he just told you live from
the yeah
he claimed no no he's he's not on the
yacht
he's at the dealership
[Laughter]
he got that check that's going to bounce
unless those games go on pc
look like
expect more and i know people think oh
addict there's no reason for them to
bring stuff day and day that's next
when they start seeing that money and
they start like what's crazy cognito is
i was told
that the only games they're gonna do is
three four year old games yeah
and it's like we got days gone which did
not come out three or four years ago god
of war came out in 2018.
this is what's going to happen this is
what's going on sooner or later you're
going to start seeing these games come
out sooner and the reason that you're
seeing these older games come out people
think it's you know three or
four-year-old games is because this
isn't a mindset that was took in place
back then
this is if they were gonna do three or
four years out in the future they would
need what studio king what studio his
heart
they wouldn't need that studio if they
were going to have that kind of mindset
they want to release games
pretty close to their release launch and
i i have a feeling that
within three years you're gonna see
games day and date on on steam because i
i do personally feel like look does it
devalue the playstation brand yes but
there's not it's a very small margin at
the very bottom
it doesn't really devour it doesn't do
anything
no no i i have to it does because there
are people but it's like i said like
there are people that would buy
playstation they couldn't buy an xbox
just them not having to buy the
playstation does devalue but the margin
is so small it doesn't hurt their bottom
line but but the person the person who
would not be betting a playstation would
then be playing that game on pc right
and we've been through this argument
where how when you really think about
the pc that you would need to play this
game
at comparable levels to playstation five
you're talking about
seventeen hundred dollars and up
it's it's a it's a lot of hot talk
around that like it's not still a lot of
people that have those type of pcs that
would buy playstation that aren't behind
the play store looking at pc i mean
playstation anyway so if the game goes
over the pc to a person that was never
going to buy a playstation and he
happens to purchase the game but those
are still lost sales that doesn't
devalue the playstation brand actually i
think it enhances it the more people
that get a chance to purchase said game
in spaces they would
never look at
never look there
regardless if you play it on a laptop
you and your college addict and you
can't go and pick up a playstation
because it's too big to look inside the
the thing
inside your dorm room but you have your
laptop regardless regardless if it's
even one that's still one person
that didn't see the value in the
playstation five because they could play
their games on pc that's that's the tech
but but they these people are still
buying it the bg's the kofis they're
still buying a ps5 oh we don't worry
about them they're in pocket yeah but
but my point is is that percentage is so
small it doesn't hurt their bottom line
right sure it devalues it to certain
demographics of people that play games
but it doesn't do it but i i think i
think the important thing is that what
they're realizing is that evaluating the
box
devaluing the box at the cost of adding
more value to the ip
is more important value it devalues the
box but it doesn't devalue the brand
right and that's i think that's the most
important yeah and i think that's what
jim sees yeah the ip is what matters yes
and you're still going to get the same
quality of games right so
how did it mean right to that
[Laughter]
he understands that the ip is what
matters yeah and getting that ip in as
many hands as possible so i agree with
you attic like
sooner rather than later
it's gonna be day and date it's gonna be
a day because i don't care what game it
is i don't care how great god award's
gonna sell great on the pc
it's not gonna sell as great as it as it
would at if it had come out day and date
with that playstation version i'm sorry
the zeitgei go back to the zeitgeist
moment every every game has its moment
literally six months after that game
came out
i saw it digitally for ten dollars i saw
it in stores for ten dollars so that's
how quick a six month period the game
would definitely value your brand right
and if you look at what nintendo does
nintendo never brings down the price
they have no right to but again when
you've made people become used to that
that's just what it is so if you want to
get mario odyssey
one bad mother completely agrees to
solve he said great way of wording it he
said value of ip is more important than
value of box in this new paradigm i
guess 100 percent the lowering the sales
is the reason uh you know
uh king jimmy don't have his 54
this is good this good discussion and
obviously first of all i'd be messy a
little bit um
lamarcus das
sir i have not seen you in uh chats
i remember a certain person always
coming in cog this will never happen
i'll super chat bet you i'll do all this
i'm here sir i'm waiting you have not
shown up sir i'm looking for it lamarcus
darts come to the front of the
congregation sir we're gonna take you
out like a man
take that l like a man bend that knee
like a man because these dudes were so
in their feelings that this could never
have i i got receipts i got tweets
i could be super messy but i'm just
going to tell his name a little bit
suppose dave a little bit more
at the dead no no because at the end of
the day these dudes
you know everybody everybody got a
high-powered pc to play these other
games you know what i'm saying but when
they stay hard they feel it's never
going to happen and this is where we got
to stop with the emotionality of gaming
you know i'm saying at the end of the
day like king is saying
is that yo this is a business and at the
end of the day if they see value right
if they see value
in putting these games these ips
elsewhere they're going to do it i think
what's interesting about this amir king
has had this discussion is that they've
got time to play with these playstations
yeah they're not playing they're not
playing them they're trying to get
they're trying to get king jimmy his
y'all yeah they're not they're not
they're not playing and said it best
colin said his bet like they hate you
i'll be honest like you said a fanboy
like they don't like you but here's the
thing though i just don't like see my
thing is accountability right yes and my
thing is and this is for the fanboys
right my thing is
now it's like well
it's not that bad because they're not
doing it you know or exactly on dnd and
this that in the third so if it happens
on day and date then what see my thing
is just a bit yo we were wrong on this
we didn't see this happen i you know
emotionally we felt they they valued
their ip because that was the argument
the argument was they've the sony brand
values therapy too much
to put this ever and and do what
microsoft is doing right so now we at
this stage these days what's this the
stages of denial and acceptance we're at
this stage now right so if it does
happen again i want the same energy
because you can't come in people podcast
talk at all it's nonsense and then you
not accountable when the things we say
happen and that's why i let king go off
you know at the end of the day you're
frozen that's good at the end of the day
yeah like people love making videos love
making videos
where's the apology video that's why i
want my knees
where's the apology video to iron lord
podcast where's the apology video to ran
outdoor xbox too where are the apology
videos the dealer game and all that like
where it is at because you can't come in
the chat spewing nonsense and not
knowing what's going on and we telling
you this is how we think it might be
trending and then it happened and
there's no accountability see that's my
problem with all the spaces and all this
other nonsense
accountability it's okay i've been wrong
a million times right i could come on
this show and say you're okay i was
wrong they don't like that though yeah
but it's just being amazing
yeah
i need i need my apology i need to be
petty
i'm 90 i listen i'm 96 percent
all the time
stop messing with me deadly and when i
put that eye on you
i just want i want the same video with
somebody facing it and exposed and all
that so i want the same energy when
you're wrong you know what i'm saying
cause if i'm wrong i'm gonna tell y'all
bro i got that one wrong i was messed up
on it i thought it was gonna go this way
but you noticed
exactly nobody got no integrity in the
game
because it's always it always gets fun
when when the first game came over right
when it was when it's death stranding
right right and they were like oh but
that's that's not really there so right
and then it was and then it was
yeah and then it was days gone right
yeah remember
i was like oh it didn't sell that well i
remember even before death training when
i was bringing up that
all of um
with the people that make um heavy rain
and stuff yes remember that remember
when the quantum dream stuff i was
bringing up to all that and people are
telling me that's not their stuff and
what i look it like sony owned the
trademark yeah i said they have no
reason we see the size we see the size
it's the same thing with with again and
don't let it go get it twisted
i tell xbox to say yo when y'all doing
something crazy
we at them you know what i'm saying so
it's like at the end of the day it's
just it's okay
to criticize it's okay to say yo i got
that one wrong
come out with the same man just be a man
about it's not about bragging about
anything it's just about being a man
when you're wrong because a lot of these
people they put their emotionality
behind the brand right and it clouds
their judgment they would never do this
to me
they will not bro they don't what was it
it's for the streets now yeah for the
streets it's for the streets down
for the streets no they don't want the
streets they want that yacht it's for
the ocean
anyway that's why i had to let this one
go i'm sorry for being messy but it was
just
i'm just tired of it bro i'm just
talking about 100 right we've been
saying this forever and the thing about
it is the crazy thing is you we get
called out right
we call xbox fanboys or whatever the
case may be i love playstation
i want playstation to be in this this is
going to make playstation so much
stronger
it's not even funny but some people
people don't want to see that right and
these are the same people capping but
you know we we're not going to buy game
pass we're going to support the damn
that's right right but this is going to
help the games explain colin put it
brutal like this is a good thing right
at the end of the day this is going to
help support santa monica this is going
to help support the god of warfare this
is going to keep us around the games
that you love is going to stay around
that same level of quality or even
higher that's what the only thing yeah
the the thing that you know that's
hurting the industry more is just that
the the zealot fan payment
because it's just like look like when i
bring up yo i want playstation for
multiplayer stuff because i want to play
more games they say well there's plenty
of multiplayer stuff left to have third
party but when i flip it and say the
best games almost every year are single
player games that third party people
make oh that that's different i don't
want that like it's like look like you
can have both you just have to demand
both and for some reason i feel like
people want microsoft to have both but
they don't want sony to have both just
kind of i just want the games on pc
so everybody can get a chance to have
fun like me
with that camera and he is being extra
with that rage this right here and
you'll probably say it ain't no
playstation controller in that box king
and i would look at you and say
i had this since day one never opened it
you ain't got no multiplayer games
you got to use the 4k heads to show that
you got to use the 4k
let me show you with the new camera let
me show you with the new camera the live
unboxing
the inaugural i'mma leave it down here
next to my pc forgotten
ridiculous i can't hear attic dying
right now
controller
you saved it for the pc
no
no no
[Music]
you're right this is for the god of war
man this is the god of war
y'all going left
you gotta have it chris look look chris
and brand new
it gotta be just right for that god of
war because it's brand new coming to you
in january
[Laughter]
i can't i can't how you feel knowing
that you're the first person to blow
into that controller i'm done listen at
the end of the day i just want to get
one more bar off okay go get that ball
get listen
at the end of the day now this is the
last point this is a little side thing i
don't know if you guys saw shout out to
tom warren um he put out a tweet about i
don't know if you saw this uh microsoft
video is unblocking microsoft edge
browser for geforce now they said that
this means you'll soon be able to play
steam pc games on xbox through geforce
now streaming so a lot of people was
like wait hold on ain't death stranding
over on
um what you call a g-force now and i'm
[ __ ]
you know what i'm saying so the question
what would be is
this i'm just pretty sure i'm just
telling you what i heard the question
will be
will death stranded because it's
currently on geforce now which is sony
game be able to be streamed on xbox
because theoretically there's a browser
or an xbox and i'm just curious if
more sony games end up being on on
geforce now that streaming service
would that be allowed i want to speak to
solve on this quick like where where you
at and i know kai uses geforce now a lot
a lot of people where are you at with
this
a background thing
well yeah
do you remember initially with geforce
now there was there was some games that
like there was an issue because they
were like wait a minute you're you're
using this as a go-between
without having asked permission so
technically you'll be able to play the
game on a platform that you can't not
supposed to
legally technically be able to play it
on right so there were some issues with
stuff getting blocked off and being said
now we cannot do this right so
the fact that it's technically possible
are you saying are they it's it's there
technically but it's not something that
that has been spoken about yet right
right right because basically yeah it's
been remember this this unlocking of
geforce now to my right edge that just
happened the question is i don't know if
i got to speak to tom and see if um he's
done his testing if if if they actually
were successful in it once it's been
unlocked because that's going to be a
curious thing i wonder i want to know if
sony would allow that get wind of it and
maybe try to block it you know what i'm
saying or like because it is interesting
that if more games go to sony games go
to geforce now then theoretically you
could stream them on xbox devices yeah
it is one of those things that that
either you just let it go wild because
it's gonna happen anyway or on your wall
garden the playstation 5 or the xbox you
try to mitigate that some way because
the same holds true for game pass on
playstation right if you open a browser
on playstation correct and you can run
game pass in that browser you can play
xbox games in your playlist right
so it's a matter of does it matter
enough to me to
try to get in the way of that or is that
just the way of the future and just
leave it be it's going to be interesting
to see
you know what what the narrative around
that is because a lot of times
we will hear the the quote unquote the
the fan the fan reasoning for this stuff
right why shouldn't it shouldn't happen
right the fanboys whatever
it oftentimes that doesn't that doesn't
go in parallel what the actual problem
is overall right so i don't know it's
just gonna be one of those things where
it's
if sony decides hey it's time to stop
getting in the way of progress in this
way and and stop continuing to try to
wall off our wall guard and more frozen
i i just i don't know it's going to be
interesting because there's so many
different ways perfectly stiff
there's yeah so many there's so many
things that can be done like when you
look at the s now and and all the all
the way to all the emulation stuff like
it's a question of
is it is it worth it yeah is it worth
the work to do it or
do we see the levels of engagement with
this type of stuff not being a big deal
the geforce thing is big just because
when you get access to when you start
talking about you can get steam
and and that platform onto one of the
other walled gardens then you start
because again
we have we have steam deck coming soon
and steam deck i'm gonna keep it real
with you it's gonna start if the steam
deck hits the way it's supposed to and
it gets in enough people's hands right
it's going to start changing the way
people think about where they buy their
buy their games yeah especially you have
a local xbox i mean game pass device you
could have you know sony exclusives on
it like if you you pc you eat right you
can you
at a cheaper price at a cheaper price at
a point entry point bottom you're good
so i beat him i'm gonna have to be real
with you man i'm i'm fading no that's
right
it's good we got it we were all out of
here but we got this last year this is
this would be quick it's the last joint
but yeah look it was very interesting
shout out to all the messages again
shout out to
ryan for pulling up man big segment it's
huge huge for the show
but uh look i'll get into i'll kind of
do a recap i don't know if for the next
time actually let's do the super chats
and then we'll get to the next one okay
give me a second yeah we got a few funny
stupid chats a little make sure i get
the last one okay so jd gamer's the last
one i'm gonna go backwards from what i
have that way
okay jd gamer 20 super chat call out the
fakers call them out by name don't let
them hide in the shadows spewing
nonsense put a name on them
i always put a name on one the only one
i see i see a blank black blank gamer
blam blam light rock the whole crew on
fire dancing to change the narrative i
had to get one person because at the end
of the day that one person we did make a
bet see the thing is i respect he just
called out like eight people yeah i
don't know about above eight people i
just know about the one person i called
out because that person said we we did
it live he was in the chat he said he's
going to be there when it happened and
your super chat was going to do it
so where's that
that's that's where i'm at
where are you these i i would like the
knees now thank you could do it okay
there we go uh let's go back we got
faisol 007 with the four pound 49 pen
super chat i will be enjoying ps bangers
on my xbox series x through the browser
and like we were just talking and the
playstation fans have to learn something
is not to bet against king
knees are mine
here we go
then we got big clown gaming five
dollars
yo king just let your song
[Music]
then we got spitty spit five dollars in
chat salute jamaican jim and the oxtail
and rice and peas
plus shots in the air the book of x
then we got flame 2 chat well
this is an xbox podcast now sorry [ __ ]
listen sir
the early xbox podcast i2 is defining
duke
that is an xbox podcast i talk about
everybody on this channel so please but
i respect them
an xbox podcast would have
the the the loyalty and the royalty of
lordship right listen we had jim ryder
you can't say that nobody said yeah we
had you right um
yo twitter is on fire with you right now
bro yeah good thing
there we go it's my easy two hours with
jack king's performance has become
history hashtag you're not enough
i do like that one that one is fun i
like what they did
then we got heart geek cheney five
dollars from chat jamaican gym pegasus
nation supports you every day
in social media
what else we get we got the mental five
dollar super chat jamaican gym puff
daddy says me can't stop me won't stop
me can't stop me won't stop call me now
a little bit of puff a little bit of it
yeah a little bit of his clothes
[Laughter]
what else then we got jd gabriel five
dollar super chat real talk i wonder if
you'll be able to play god of war on
xbox series x because of that new
browser update so we all have your games
now
yo
they lose
smitty smith
five dollar super chat
jamaican gym is all naughty and not for
player
then we have splendiferous two dollar
super chat attic put some respect
pondine man worldwide
okay
we got flare five dollar super chat
guess we welcome santa monica like san
diego let's roll out the red carpet for
insomniac sucker punch blue point it's
about the games right
it's true right and it is
oh my god oh look at jess guarding it
hold on i gotta shout out the legendary
just going for xbox best xbox on the net
right now
shout out to jazz oh my god i love you
guys xbox too man
there we go spinny spit five dollars two
chat these sony fanboys lawns must look
like swiss cheese from all the goalposts
moving word of advice please stop saying
never the book of acts yeah yeah
it never hurts you never say never the
emotionality of fanboys
then we got jazz with the 10 pound super
chat
professing his love for mayo
shout out to the lord of video and
shrimp
that was that hurt my heart the other
day when i saw that that was bad
that was that was bad i loved the
video and everything but that's my
turn-based lloyd man i love jasmine
then we got gabenomics with the 10 rupee
100 rupee uh super chat waiting for king
to say thanks for beta testing the game
ps gamers i'ma play the finish game on
my pc a year later
there we go smitty smith five dollar
super chat to all those sony fanboys fix
your face
[Laughter]
then we have bunty two dollars
enough respect king from the don dada
i love [ __ ]
what else
there we got we already got jd anybody
after jd game we gotta come up yeah we
got one bad mother hold on baby roll
back a little bit because it jumps me
okay so we got
jay nichols five dollar super chat sony
fanboy and pegasus nation and their
spaces are crazy some old children oh
we ain't doing that we ain't doing that
yeah yeah yeah you're doing that salute
let's not do that no personal salute
exactly
then we got one bad mother five dollar
super chat doesn't playstation on pc
sound organic xbox error being messy
[Laughter]
shout out to my bad mother man salute so
let's move on i'll do a summary because
i know poor addict is dying and i don't
know if any of you did it first of all
before i start um did anybody watch the
it was a pay wall
well wall street journal um
phil interview did anybody catch it the
moment i said subscribe i clicked yeah i
know i know so because i i watched it
but i just want to make sure i can
comment look two interviews recently
again we want to salute our phil and
matt booty uh phil was on the wall
street journal
and um yeah again it was a little
paywall drink but i had to put the bread
down for phil man i wanted to know what
he was doing so look you know pretty
much i just get a recap you know he kind
of doubled down obviously on the vr
thing you talk about the supply chains
you mentioning about um they're still
trying to improve that they said
obviously with the s because the die
size is smaller that they'll be able to
make more
you know he's still sticking on his 18
million public game move really don't
say it for that she tried to get him
she's like well we heard 30.
he stuck to the company line you know
what it says or that um he has some
interesting things about xcloud he
pretty much talked about it being a
convenience feature they're seeing a lot
of growth in um brazil and demand for
other markets as far as azure and server
blades newer tech improvements on
latency they're excited the key thing he
said though to me said on diversity of
the business model he said you know not
everyone is going to be on game pass and
he says he wants it to be where they
have it on retail someone's going to
have it on retail some some people are
not going to want it on the game pass
some people not going to go to retail
and some people are not going to go to x
cloud so he wants to have these multiple
revenue models right so pretty much
leaving it to the player you know i'm
saying as far as where they want to go
because i think she kind of talked about
the future like do you see she literally
asked him straight up about the death of
the console king and she said um you
know as far as the future to be able to
play game pass on my smart
drive she actually said different he
said you know because she said you know
we're getting to that point what about
not needing a physical box and she said
like he said pretty much that
streaming's still growing and his plan
he said but he still he said their plan
for right now is to still have a
dedicated high fidelity local box he
said his future for xbox is a mixture of
both the streaming and the local
hardware and then he said his strategy
this is the key word he said his
strategy doesn't involve xbox selling
only consoles to be successful or
selling only pc to be successful or
selling only xcloud success he said the
way it's set up with infrastructure and
such those guys is for a diversity model
let the player decide what's best for
them and all the combination of the
models right
yeah exactly the bayonet and all that
like he's he he's talking about
the gun
yeah he's talking about we could eat we
don't have to have everybody on like we
could eat with all these bottles kind of
things
right and you know what else i thought
was interesting is he mentioned about
acquisitions they're not done but he
also said
that
because i want to shout out grub and we
would talk about behind the scenes like
that um there's been a talk about like
yo money has to be spent because the
price could go up right however it felt
kind of flexed it was kind of like oh no
no we don't got no quote on when we have
to do it by this time or we have to he
said we're going to do it
but
you know there's no rush like we have so
they're they're taking that time so
there's a lot to take from it you know
um i get the sign like they're taking
their time
with the acquisitions making it the
right move and some people even search
out the jazz at xbox too if he's still
in there they actually said sometimes
this is actually a call out
to um devs that may have been on the
fence like oh you know what they're
still looking all right let's you know
get back
i think a little bit of has to do with
the you know people keep saying they
keep overreaching that doesn't make
sense and i think he's like look like
we have this money we have to spend this
money but we don't
we're not going to just go out there and
blow money because we want to we want to
you know i know some things don't make
sense to you because you don't have
access to back doors that they say
but just because you don't think us
buying that company don't make sense
doesn't mean there's not a reason you
just don't know the reason
right and i think they did coming out
there
and i think i think he was just coming
out there and he's like look like
you guys might think that we're going
out here buying stuff and we have this
money we have to sell doesn't mean we
have to sell it and we're not just
buying stuff just to buy stuff
to me it was a flex
because the way i look at it is like oh
no no no the inflation ain't bothering
us the price go up next year so like it
don't rush us we doing how we do there's
no clock over there yes that's the vibe
i got that type of thing but um
because listen satya already told you
that they're still in acquisition mode
right um to to fulfill the model that
phil has uh explained the three uh prong
approach uh to fulfill that cloud uh
structure to fill the physical structure
and to fulfill uh uh the gaming in this
space structure it has to have a lot of
of of games to fill these voids right
right um you're not going to overwork
your studios to the point that you're
putting out uh crappy games right you
want them to give them enough time to
make games right and we know games now
take at least five years
really good games to complete some games
could be done a little bit earlier but
they're going to be put into tears so
you don't want to overwork studios you
we already hear stuff about crunch and
stuff like that so if you have the
resources to purchase more studios to to
facilitate
more games why not do it oh yeah yeah
and you know what you know what else i
think it is uh king i think he's coming
out there is like
look
we sitting on our stone
we have eyes on companies we want and
we're getting those companies we ain't
just buying random companies because we
have to spend money we're buying those
companies like this
yeah speaking of which you know shout
out again shout out to jez again i i
want to shout out i don't know if you
heard about that project challenge
yeah
you know
another rpg
like to me it's like they're putting
that that they're putting that flag in
the ground and they're like if you're an
rpg fan the only place to play is on axe
well they definitely got the abundance
there and then so that was pretty much
the gist of the the paid shout out to
wall street journal i gave y'all a bag
y'all plugging y'all right there but um
you know it was a great idea
yeah that uh i got it i got to get in
there it was great reporting you know i
forgot to lay the wonderful lady's name
but um yeah phil was there i saw i still
sort of switched on the back of the
shelf i would shelf watch it i was
pocket watching phil the shelf was still
the switch was still back there with the
kojima statue go you know shelf watch
2021.
anyway so booty interview i don't know
if you want me to recap it or y'all saw
it i could recap it really quick it's up
to y'all oh
okay so look i saw it all right so you
did it all right so good let's get uh uh
added the autonomous software to start
first what you guys thought
um
matt booty interview was interesting
just because he went in and kind of like
with the kind of funny guys right they
themselves said it like we're not
necessarily they had snow bike there
right but they were not necessarily the
xbox guys so
um it was interesting to hear him talk
about one like the stuff that he does on
the side right you would think he's he
has so much time he he doesn't have a
lot of time
he just spends his time coding like
coding and just like so that was very
interesting to know about him and kind
of how he sort of
he sort of unwinds and he unwinds by by
coding um
the stuff that was most interesting
obviously the stuff that stood out that
they asked him about everwild and kind
of where it was and and the idea that
you know they were like wait a minute
you know when the public hears
kind of a reset they're like oh it's in
trouble and then he made it clear it's
like sometimes that wording isn't
necessarily
correct whereas the way a studio thinks
about kind of
like like a soft sort of reset and what
what the public perceives is that is is
not the same so
essentially saying that the vision
everything that we've been working on is
still there right it probably needed
some tweaking in terms of direction but
it wasn't necessarily a thing where we
just scrapped everything and started
from scratch so and you know he's very
confident that whatever rare's making
whatever wild is going to be great so
that that was super interesting to hear
i love the transparency there wherever
while yeah i like how he doubled down on
everwild though yeah i like how he
doubled down on it and he said like a
myriad of decisions
all these little decisions that turned
all these little mini decisions right
there sort of makeup that make up
you know the direction of a game
and oftentimes when we hear something we
just hear very black and white like yeah
it's like yeah i said oh they had to
start again oh it's broken
and it's there's a lot more nuance to it
than that so that was good to hear yeah
um then he talked about perfect docking
and and crystal d
and he was like
and i mean at the end of the day what he
talked about he was like you know
the opportunity was there he admitted
like yes when you look at it it's like
this is weird this has never happened
but we would be the opportunities there
for whatever reason he didn't go into
why he's just like look they were
available and we were like you know what
let's do this yeah and and it feels like
hey if you if you can get a aaa team to
work with you for whatever the reason
may be
and they're there working with you to
build this game whatever so i mean again
we go back to the transparency like he
he tried to be and they didn't they
didn't go crazy with the questions right
they didn't ask him all this others you
know off the wall stuff then he talked
about red fall
and you know how that looked and how
interesting it was just to sort of be
like hey
we're working with the guys that made
this honor they made prey and they're
applying those same sort of gameplay
tenets to this sort of
this multiplayer centric game with those
same sort of sensibility so he's super
excited about that um i'm assuming we're
going to see it next year he's supposed
to be coming and then the most
interesting stuff
was when they asked him about well okay
the criticism of microsoft is that they
haven't had that game that hashtag just
one the one that's comparable to what
sony first party games are doing
and he said it very eloquently he was
like listen these are games we know the
horizons the uncharted they have they
have these universal these what he
called universal themes that sort of
appeal to everyone right that these
games have
this certain type of production value
and the characters and the story
everything is is very
well realized and you know that is a
quality product that costs a lot of
money to make and he made it very clear
he's like we hear you
and that's important for us that's a
that's an important goal for us to reach
yes so
in one some way shape or form
that type of game is happening at my
xbox studios and i think
for everybody was listening to that that
was what they wanted to hear like listen
we we've heard rumors we heard this and
the other
is that type of game in production at
xbox studios and he made it clear just
to cut you because this was important
this was the key for me obviously i'm
the leader of the hashtag
so i i'm looking to see if he's gonna
throw a dart you know what i'm saying
like and the key what he said is at
first he started he said look i don't
want to do
he said it portfolio bingo right yes
which is i'm gonna go to everybody and
be like yo you got to make this the
stuff king was talking about right he's
like no we're not doing that right but
at the same time he said it would how
beautifully
which was you know
we
still understand the value of these epic
stories these epic characters these
worlds that you want to live in and care
about with the big budget right and he
still he said well we still got those
still coming and we do respect sony for
some of the joints that they doing too
but again it's not from a standpoint of
like yo i'm gonna go to each studio and
be like yo
you need to you know you did you you're
not saying that kind of thing
again he's letting them do them but
trust and believe it was kind of one of
those things got like trusted believe
those type of games is coming because we
understand and that's all i wanted to
hear that was all i was like yes um i
put my gun away yeah good compulsion got
me composure just came out and said yo
carl we got you you know what i'm saying
so i'm good on that but it gave me the
vibe that it'd be more maybe more than
hashtag just one hashtag yes it seems
like a couple of things other
productions in that way yeah reveal
itself at some point in time yeah at
some point in time they're gonna have to
you know take on that type of genre and
and show that they can be versatile in
that space like i said before quantum
break was a really good game it just had
poor control and you know that was their
stuff but um they're gonna make a game
that's gonna you know please the masses
that want that type of game and i'm
pretty sure sony is going to make
multiplayer games that's going to please
their fan base as well so it's not like
these companies don't hear you it's just
you know hey these games take time so
yeah and i know he knows exactly what
yeah what he's you know absolutely and
that that's what i was good to hear it i
love all the stuff no put a smile on
your face yo man i i loved it um
told you that she was gonna get a
baseball game man
hey we never know that browser might
hook up but we might get all the games
i'm gonna deal with you
did you watch it
i can't ally did you guys the uh the
booty interview nope nope all right cool
look let's look at you
real quick can you find me on miss super
chat from a mass erect please yeah if we
miss this show we got to get them yeah
like i gotta find master rex
that's right go go get that
[Laughter]
oh um yeah look we're gonna finish up
not gonna go get anything named master
right now go get that full oh at the end
of the day
i thought was it you know why you said
that twice it was funny um
yeah shout out to slow bike mike and
those guys shout out to blessings i get
great interview
you know i loved king would have loved
hearing him talk about i forgot he was
part of the midway days yeah back in the
day he was doing the cruise so i think i
think he's
he's referring to the two dollar super
chat from mass erect sorry addict pepsi
is the tcl of soda drinks
wow
but i have that here but did we get
judge did we get jezebel i think we
missed jazz too he had put one in the
mail yeah we got jay nichols
we got the mayo one and then just put up
another one that i haven't read yet oh
okay okay i just want to make sure we
didn't miss it so master if that wasn't
it master right just just no that had to
be a dead that had to be it had to be i
think it fit now he's gonna let us know
but yeah but if it wasn't just add us
some more read that yeah i think the
other key he said i'll finish up
something going on we gotta get out of
here is that um
he said what i always said two which is
like
you got all these studios right
but what he said is when you're doing
the acquisition phase remember like we
talked about earlier king these guys had
stuff they always already working on
they're trying to get out the door
psychonauts 2 was already working or
trying to get out the door out of worlds
with obsidian they was trying to work on
it getting out the door but he's saying
like he's really excited to see the next
round of each of those studios
yeah underneath the because he's he's
super pumped yeah underneath the banner
with the budget like he's super pumped
to see what double fine is going to do
with the fake stuff the real stuff the
written yeah i'm saying dialed you free
of your obligations and now you forget i
thought that part was cool not anything
going on playstation yeah and
again so that they don't have to worry
about taking risks and getting out there
i thought it was a great interview but
he was really he doesn't come outside a
lot matt doesn't come outside a lot but
it was cool to see a lot of studios to
look over yeah
i'm talking about oh i let them do them
no he don't yeah
i think his excitement his neck is on
the line so he over there making sure
y'all good right
i think i think his excitement is
you know you've seen what they do
on on a budget like not necessarily like
they're writing them blank checks but
this is what now you can see what they
can do
on a proper budget yeah yeah yeah
no it is what it is but let's get these
super chats that we gotta get up out of
here man this is a long one
wait till they get them
cool
they've got plenty we have
[Laughter]
let me see that
okay
it was no that was stitch though stitch
said that
stitch said the thing about the pepsi it
wasn't it wasn't massive right yeah
master right just just add us man
because we want to make sure i want to
make sure that we read it we're ready
for you yeah
jay necklace
with the two super chat saying hey
addict pepsi is the tco of soda drinks
i think i just double checked it
he even said in the chat it was it okay
okay so
so i guess stitch said the same thing
but they said the same thing out there
pepsi is the tcs
i remember that i remember i don't drink
either one of them i've been drinking
like these gatorade zeros so like stay
away from this told to remind you for
iron lord podcast good day fire show
okay
then we have uh the matt massarec two
dollars super chat savvy missed my super
chat yeah we got that there we have jay
nichols five dollars would like to
apologize to the lords for a bad comment
i got up the most respect and again i
apologize for name dropping thank you
brother i appreciate it we're trying not
to even you know we try not to keep it
personal even with people exactly with
much love
then we have jazz corden with the five
pound super chat can any of you do a
british accent though
so is there a reason people are talking
about uh dragon age position in the chat
i don't know sorry if i needed a british
accent though a br i can do like uh
or something
whatever whatever you're
yeah i'm not i'm not particularly sure
that i might be able to do that jazz uh
you know uh you know or i could do a
really like a really bad bad like heavy
one like like uh let's go let's go let's
get to solve boss
the reason i asked about the dragon age
because i'm literally like
on low listening to the mid view that's
why i that's why i like went like this
i'm like can they hear my oh he doesn't
say oh no no no you're good you're good
you're good shout out to jazz man
her giddy saying that i missed one from
him too
sorry guys yeah we we missed it yeah
guys yeah i i'm scrolling and sometimes
it jumps man i try to run back at iron
lord's podcast if you if you missed
something we'll say now yeah we got so
we got flame two dollars we chat just
remember cog it's all in good fun of
course we're just laughing at your
british accent he kills us
british accent yeah he kills us for his
american accent which oh he does yeah he
doesn't know it's hilarious when he
makes fun of red you know
it's hilarious so check that out yeah
the other one i was going to do was one
from like faulty towers
talking about bum looking i don't want
to die
[Laughter]
little bum look at you
there we go let's get that that's what
i'm talking about
looking not
except for the whatever whatever ones we
missed harget please uh
if you bring it down we will just read
it what's his name
all right cool so let's get about here
paul with the recent announcement of
saudi first party titles like god of war
coming to pc do you think this sets the
stage for more of these titles
eventually to come day and date on pc
choices are a akw say you sound like
you're from
essex uk
hey no sony still values their first
party titles and will only put them on
pc after a year or two when playstation
4 5 and 4 sales begin to slow down
b
yeah we'll have a key
that's a lie
yes sony knows first party games on pc
will not send you something soft will
not damage their brand these exclusives
will eventually come day and date to pc
only a matter of time or c i don't care
what happens just suit just here to
salute whatever worldwide jim does next
for the company
[Music]
gotcha so shout out to everybody again
shout out to the legendary chris
grinnell sony liverpool's gorilla games
i read that diagnosis
you know tremendous history man love
what he's doing with the urban zoo
sports platform send some love out to
them again great stories great history
and of course there's another one
another one okay yeah you're doing it
you sent multiple of them all right cool
and attic where can the fine people find
you what you got going on sir
you can find me on uh
i will most likely be streaming on the
iop twitch channel tomorrow so uh i'll
be on the lookout for that it's probably
gonna be demon souls
so uh you know if you guys want to see
me not struggle on demon souls you can
uh definitely go oh nice like that okay
and enjoy that and i'm gonna go ahead
and put it in here
with his shirt off
yeah i got a lot of i got a lot of hate
for that because
he was too slow so i literally like he
took his shirt off and just ran around i
said this guy's crazy
why are we getting spammed with the
twitch all right we got five twitches
okay cool twit trick twitch
all right you know that's been pretty
much it attic
yeah that's it all right no doubt and uh
software can you find people find you
let me read these super chats first so
the first one i did read from harvey
jamaican gym pegasus nation supports you
every day in social media so
i read that one definitely read that one
then they have another one from margie
can't think just you the u.s and the
european markets for grain pass to grow
need to sell a hardware and other
reasons push game pass over there
there's growth potential in u.s europe
japan but those people can uh but those
people can afford seventy dollars per
game this is just starting
um yeah you can catch me at work because
i'm back back to doing it actually uh
before i go to work though i'm gonna
record this week's lord minute with lady
uh april we're gonna be talking about
the uh gta definitive trilogy what do
you think about those uh those upgrades
no doubt and of course lou today excuse
me um worldwide jim ryan
you know able to make his appearance
thank you for taking the time out your
busy day you know sony europe oh man
i'm i'm me oh you okay i didn't know if
he was back back oh he left he left
right now okay guys we'll make sure
thank you
thank you for facilitating that that
interview for us you know because to get
christopher down and get jim ryan on one
show it's a mega show for us man oh man
it's out of control
yo he came over left his head in the
playstation controller that's crazy man
that's crazy
i jim crazy baby
look at the five people find you what
you got going on sir you can find me
trolling you dudes
[Laughter]
you can find me anywhere you try to hide
me there
right there looking over your shoulder
saying i told you so
you don't let the boot off people next
oh no no no i realize i realize why they
don't bother me no more i realized why
you leave me alone i've realized what
i've done to you
i have you know you you
call in the fight throwing a towel
yo that that is kind of true though you
don't want your shirt you don't have the
back and forth with king anymore you
really don't see it anymore
leave my man alone that's what i always
say
leave my man alone
all late generals are beating the
submission this is the final straw this
is it right here this is the one that
broke the camel's back this is the one
this is the one
that will never happen yeah a lot of
dudes
you're holding on to that web slinger
you're holding on to him so tight you're
like please oh god
let me say the last thing
the last thing is y'all y'all worried
about that web slinger you're worried
about that stuff right there no no no we
already got you we already own you on pc
what um what what what is the last coup
de gras
the last bastion for you guys because
y'all all huddled up in one little fort
and it's raining on your head because
you ain't got no roof but y'all was like
they can't get in through the front door
when i play playstation games on that
xbox browser on my xbox
and i stream that
that's when we worldwide
are you going to make a video for that
dude
i love jim jim is the best
shout out to nixon jim
that's amazing
salute to you man this is your day you
called it you know you've been calling
for a while and you know just
people have to deal with the realities
of the business and that's just what it
is but um so you would get those couple
super chats and we got we really got a
role but we got gamer by choice five
dollars super chat just wanted to
support the channel and i hope it helps
to get worldwide jim back on the podcast
again salute great show
we will we will see him again i'm sure i
think we'll see him okay
then we got this
in january
shaking his food rebellion
and we got sage with the uh shout out to
say seven months the lord go jim ryan is
tired of eating chicken back all the
time he's ready to eat
like phil spencer that's hilarious we're
eating good then we got suicide kings
member for 12 months thank you so much
i had to share my time with the ravens
today but again an awesome show thank
you so much brother salute salute
then we got flame five dollar super chat
one last thing we got bamboozled over
that fable thing last week we got played
like a day like a dang fiddle and my
sunday was ruined yeah no a lot of
people turned out to be nothing yeah
i'll be another day subs coming but just
somebody jumped the gun earlier oh real
quick teespring merch charlie online
just cop that new film dominance
pullover premium hoodie salute to
charlie online getting that drip kick is
in the other dimension but look that's
it your fantastic show again grinnell's
christmas thank you brother he's back
chris goodell thank you brother
worldwide jim thank you brothers taking
it out taking the time
new rp next sunday we up out of anybody
got anything else before we roll
peace people see you next week
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you